Ich weiß, komische
Uhrzeit. Normalerweise bin ich entweder
früher oder später am Start.
Aber nachdem ich
Urlaub hab,
Sache ist bloß die, ich weiß nicht, ob von euch jetzt viele
da sind. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber ich glaub, die meisten sind fertig arbeiten,
sind schon auf dem Weg heim oder so. Michael,
fünf Spieljahre, Naumeter am Start. Nice.
Um nicht zu sagen,
Nice.
Excellent.
So. Irgendwas stimmt
mit meinem Headset nicht. Moment, ich muss es mal kurz abmachen.
Herr Schlocker!
Danke für den Prime Sub.
Wartet mal, ich kurz Headset raus machen.
So, jetzt bin ich
wieder da. Übrigens, Franzosen
scheint das Wort Poggers zu
verwirren, denn, wartet mal.
Morgen, KS, Alter.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, Franzosen scheint das Wort Poggers
zu verwirren, weil
ich hab mir einen Char gemacht,
in einem MMO, der Poggers heißt.
Da hab ich mit ein paar Franzosen gespielt
und die haben im Teamspeak
die ganze Zeit gesagt, Pogger,
Pogger.
Die konnten Poggers nicht sagen.
Pogger, Pogger.
Pogger.
Ähnlich im TS, im Discord, Alter, hab ich TS gesagt.
Packweight, Alter.
Nein, nein, ganz so oldschool,
das ist TS, das ist auch nicht mehr.
Pogger, haben die gesagt, Pogger.
Pogger.
In der Frage werden wir heute nachgehen,
ob es wirklich so kacke gewesen ist,
weil ich habe zufälligerweise
bei mir eine
Windows ME ISO gefunden.
Wenn man dort die MD5-Summen
kontrolliert, wird man auch feststellen,
das ist ein originales Windows ME ISO
ohne großartigen,
äh, was ist ohne großartigen, ohne gar keine
Änderungen, sonst hätt's nicht den
passenden Hashwert.
Das hab ich zufälligerweise
bei mir gefunden.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, wir probieren das,
aber aus dem Dachboden, ja, genau.
Das ISO-File hab ich vom Dachboden geholt,
korrekt, korrekt.
Packweight.
Mit Key.
Ey, ein Windows 5, äh,
Windows ME Key
hab ich tatsächlich noch.
Ich hab auch noch ein Windows 95
und Windows 98 Key.
Ich hab sogar noch irgendwo
das originale Windows 98 SE Handbuch.
Ja, Key hab ich,
Key hab ich auch.
Wir probieren das heute mal aus,
weil, also, der Hintergrund ist folgendes.
Erstens hab ich irgendwie
übelst Bock, mal wieder ein altes Windows zu installieren.
Nicht, weil's irgendwie für irgendwas
brauchbar wäre.
Und das Zweite ist,
ich würde gerne mal das hier ausprobieren.
Das ist richtiges High-IQ-Projekt.
Und zwar
GitHub Browser Service.
Äh.
Wenn ich noch
Browser Service, wenn ich noch richtig,
suchen könnte, da kann man nämlich
mit einem,
mit einem Proxy,
neue Webseiten
im Internet Explorer 6
anzeigen lassen.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Man installiert sich was auf einer Linux-Kiste
und trägt das dann als Proxy
in Internet Explorer ein
und unter der Haube
rendert das quasi
die Linux-Kiste
und schickt das dann mit ein bisschen JavaScript rüber
als Bilddateien
in den Internet Explorer.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal ausprobieren.
Es ist eigentlich,
auch so ein komplett unsinniges Stück
Software, aber cool, dass es funktioniert.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, wenn wir das schon mal
ausprobieren, also hier oben sieht man
eine Proxy-Adresse.
Wenn wir das eh schon ausprobieren,
dann können wir das auch mal so machen.
Als Bild, ja.
Ein Video könnte, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob der Internet Explorer 6 in irgendeiner Art
und Weise Videos kann.
Wahrscheinlich GIFs, wobei GIFs ja
nicht wirklich als Video durchgehen, oder?
Mario, danke schön für den Sub.
Leute, gehen GIFs als Video durch,
ja oder nein? Also ich finde
GIFs gehen
nicht als Video durch, weil
für mich, also es gibt zwei Sachen, die für mich
Videos ausmachen. Erstens,
sagen wir mal,
mehr als 5 FPS, wobei
man muss sagen, mehr als 5 FPS,
das geht ja mittlerweile, wobei
das nicht wirklich, aber der hier zum Beispiel,
guckt mal,
der hier hat definitiv mehr als 5 FPS.
Guckt mal, wie flüssig der danst.
Also der hat mehr als, also
für mich machen Videos aus,
erstens mal mehr als 5 FPS und vor allem
machen Videos aus, also moderne
Videos, encodete Videos aus,
dass die eben nicht Bild für Bild
gespeichert werden müssen, sondern
eben als Bilddifferenz zu unterschiedlichen
Keyframes und das ist es ja soweit, ich weiß
bei GIF nicht. Deswegen ist die Frage,
gehen GIFs als Videos durch
oder nicht?
Wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, GIFs sind nur
bewegte Bilder, würdet ihr sagen,
ja Max, aber jedes Video sind nur bewegte Bilder.
Also ich finde,
also ich finde, GIFs gehen nicht als Video durch.
Auch wenn sie animiert sind, aber
Video ist was anderes.
Ja, wir können es mit GIFs coole Sachen machen, ja.
Wie zum Beispiel transparent im Hintergrund
und sowas, das kannst du ja beispielsweise mit H.264
bis heute
nicht machen, da musst du irgendwelche
ollen anderen Formate verwenden.
Augur?
Ja, für sowas ist es tatsächlich
sinnvoll, zum Beispiel, es gibt ja
Leute, die wollen sich so eine richtig
Oldschool
äh
Spielekiste hinstellen oder sowas
und keine Ahnung, wirklich
Windows 98, Windows 95 oder so drauf
oder Windows ME
oder XP oder so, wobei XP
gibt es einen halbwegs aktuellen
Firefox noch für Windows XP?
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht, ne?
Ich glaube, das ist alles, ich glaube, das ist alles
eing...
eingestellt. Ich glaube, den letzten Firefox,
den es für Windows XP gab, der ist bestimmt
auch schon gut und gern 5, 6 Jahre alt.
Wahrscheinlich eher 6, 7 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Zumindest habe ich gedacht, wir probieren das aus.
Ja, es gibt noch den alten
Opera, den gibt es noch, den
als es noch nicht
China-Chinesen-Opera war.
Also nicht Our Data Now
Opera war.
Ja, aber selbst der,
also der letzte, der letzte richtige
Opera-Opera, selbst der
hat ja Probleme damit, moderne Webseiten
anzuzeigen.
Eisflieg, danke für den Sub. Ich meine, wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass Facebook, wenn du es neu
aufmachst, glaube ich,
beim allerallerersten Mal, ich glaube, irgendwie
27 MB insgesamt verteilt
über mehrere Request JavaScript oder so
runterlädt. Hat doch mal
letztens einer irgendwo
irgendwo analysiert,
27 MB JavaScript, also es gibt
nicht ein fettes JavaScript-File,
so ist es nicht, also dürft ihr euch jetzt nicht vorstellen,
dass das Ding irgendwie einen Download macht,
da irgendwie 27 MB, aber wenn du das
alles zusammenrechnest, was das einbindet,
Tracking-Zeug,
User-Interface-Zeug, alles, braucht Facebook
irgendwie erstmal 27 MB,
Kram, das ist überhaupt
gedenkt zu laufen.
Und das wird bei, das wird wahrscheinlich
bei Instagram oder den
anderen Dingern nicht viel anders sein.
Das Gute ist, dass das mit der Zeit
alles gecached ist. Wir können ja schon mal
die VM erstellen, wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind.
Ja, zufällig bei mir
gespawnt hier auf dem Desktop, die Windows ME
ISO. Wir haben ja noch in Windows 11
laufen, warum, was das da macht,
weiß ich nicht. Und wir haben
hier noch,
Proxmox-Dinger laufen, die kann ich
eigentlich mal löschen, oder?
Die Proxmox-Dinger, die braucht
doch eigentlich gar keiner mehr.
Open Directory,
Machines, ja, das
löschen wir jetzt mal hier.
Wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind.
Remove,
weil die brauchen, werden wir nie wieder
für irgendwas verwenden. Das war mal zum Ausprobieren,
das war's. Wofür die
Windows XP-Geschichte hier ist,
wie groß ist denn der Müll?
24 Gig, was hat man damit gemacht?
Hat noch irgendjemand einen Plan, warum wir hier Windows 11
installiert hatten? Ich weiß
es nicht mehr. Zumindest
kann es nicht so akut sein.
Wo sei ich der Papierkorb hier?
Ey, ich hasse dieses
neue Menü hier oben. Das ist so nervig,
Alter. Ich habe eh keine Ahnung,
was an dem Menü jetzt so schlecht
gewesen ist. Ich meine,
es sieht vielleicht nicht
super krass 2023
Bleeding Edge aus, aber sieht Windows
an sich eh nicht.
Und ist vor allem
super
zerstückelt. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel,
das können wir übrigens jetzt gleich unter
Windows ME uns angucken.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel
für zerstückelte Sachen in Windows
ist ja immer das hier. Also nicht
das Menü, das auch.
Mein Lieblingsding, was ich immer
gerne zeige, ist das hier.
Ich würde sagen, 16x16
Icons.
Also das ist so ein
ein wildes
zusammen
gewürfelter
Krempel aus
40 Jahren Windows.
Und vor allem, man muss auch mal ehrlich sagen,
die meisten dieser Icons hier
die meisten dieser Icons hier, auch die
neuen, die sehen einfach
richtig scheiße
aus.
Die sehen einfach richtig kacke aus.
Also anscheinend
möchte niemand seine,
seine Icons unter Windows customizen.
Gut, unter Windows möchtest du ja eh nix mal customizen,
weil du ja eigentlich so gut wie nix mal customizen kannst.
Ich meine, du kannst ja nicht mehr mehr im Ordner auf die
Taskleiste ziehen. Was ich euch gleich zeigen werde,
Hexenwerk
in Windows ME ging das.
Ob man es glaubt oder nicht, aber
die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht
da, Leute.
Legen wir mal ein neues VM an.
So, next, next.
Ich hoffe,
dass es überhaupt noch
VMware Tools gibt.
Für Windows ME und sowas.
Hyper-V unsupported.
Habe ich auch nicht vor, VMware. Macht dir keine Gedanken.
Windows ME, Windows ME.
Number of Processors.
Chat gibt.
Wie viele CPUs konnte Windows ME?
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, das Ding konnte genau
eine CPU und ein Core. Fertig.
Mehr ging damals nicht.
Für alles andere hast du Windows
NT oder Windows 2000.
Windows 2000 war es damals
wahrscheinlich eher schon gebraucht.
Ich glaube, mehr
ging nicht. Gucken wir mal.
Wir gucken mal, was passiert.
How many cores
supported Windows ME?
Das Windows ME
support dual processors. Nope.
Best bet is Windows 2000.
Ja, dachte ich mir.
Es gibt kein
Multi-Core-Support.
Multi-CPU-Support in Windows ME.
Aber das hatte ich auch irgendwo noch
im Hinterkopf.
Dein erster PC
hat Windows ME.
Ganz
ehrlich, ich bin nämlich
der Meinung, bis jetzt zumindest, gewesen,
dass Windows ME nicht
so kacke ist, wie es immer
dargestellt wird. Ich meine, Windows ME
war kein großer Schritt
von Windows 98 aus.
Aber Windows ME hat ein paar coole Sachen.
Unter anderem die Optik, die
ein bisschen moderner damals
ausgesehen hat als Windows 98.
Aber Windows ME hat ein paar coole Sachen.
Windows ME hatte, glaube ich, als allererstes so Consumer
Windows ICS.
Kennt ihr noch Windows ICS?
Wer weiß noch, was das ist?
Das war das Windows
Internet Connection Sharing
ICS. Das konntest du quasi
wenn du
damals hatte man ja noch ganz gerne DSL-Modems
direkt an der Kiste
dran angeschlossen. Und damals
konnte man zum Beispiel, wenn man
ICS eingeschaltet hat,
konnte man quasi ganz normal so ein bisschen
auf NAT-Router machen mit seinen
Windows ME. Internet
Connection Sharing hieß das damals.
Das war, glaube ich,
bei Windows ME neu. Und ich hab das
ausführlichst benutzt.
ICS ist, das könnte auch
Kalender hat, heißt aber das Internet Connection
Sharing war das damals. So.
Also, komm, wir hauen jetzt mal richtig rein.
1000, Moment, was?
Maximum, okay, Maximum RAM
supported Windows ME.
Irgendwie hat die Musik einfach
random aufgehört gerade.
Mag das nicht, wenn die Playlists
so random sind?
Also mit random, also so
unterschiedlich laut. Das ist immer,
anstrengend.
Das Beste hier.
Pinguin-Strecke.
Äh, genau, ich wollte eigentlich
gucken, was das Maximum an RAM ist.
Maximum RAM
supported Windows
ME. Was das ist.
Ein Gigabyte, was? Limitations.
Wie jetzt?
Okay, ich stell mal ein
Gigabyte ein. Äh, ja.
Ein Gig RAM ein. Mal gucken,
was passiert.
Mehr geht nicht.
Gucken wir mal. Ich mein, es kann natürlich sein, dass er
schlicht und ergreifend einfach nicht mehr erkennt.
Next.
Lassen wir's
gleich ins Internet?
Ich bin ja skeptisch, ob das
so eine gute Idee ist. Aber ganz davon abgesehen,
ich mein, was soll großartig passieren?
Der connectet irgendwelche offiziellen Microsoft-Sachen.
Also, das ist nicht so wild.
Next. Next.
Next.
Acht Gig.
Äh, ich glaube,
8 Gigabyte Disk-Quadrat.
Das war damals riesig groß. Das sollte reichen für alles, was man so vorhat.
Updates. Stimmt, wie macht...
Gab das eigentlich für Windows ME einen Service-Pack?
Gab's der SP1
oder sowas?
Windows ME Update-CD Release 2.2.
Ich glaube
eher nicht, ey.
Stimmt, wie updatet man...
Wie hat man
eigentlich damals seine Betriebssysteme
geupdatet? Also, ich mein, ich weiß,
es gab damals ein Windows Update
Service. Da konntest du damals
auch, das ging dann nur im Internet Explorer,
musstest du auf die Windows-Seite und so.
Aber, wie hat man
das, wie hat man das ohne Internet-Connections
damals gemacht? Gab's dann...
Ja gut, doch, doch, klar.
Damals hat man, damals hat man sich dann die aktuelle
PC-Welt oder Chip oder, oder,
oder, äh, ich glaub,
die CT hatte damals auch keine, hatte
damals auch keine CDs dabei. Ich weiß nicht
mehr genau. Ähm, gekauft
und hat sich dann die aktuellen Service-Packs
installiert. Okay, also,
was haben wir hier? Soundkarte, so, erstmal.
Let's go.
Äh, how to
update Windows ME?
Das würd mich echt mal interessieren.
Hier.
Der erklärt uns das.
Updates für Windows
ME im Jahr 2022.
Kannst du Windows ME
noch verwenden? Vielleicht nicht als
Tagesfahrer.
Ich hab das Gefühl, hier ist
irgendwie der Browser der Meinung, er muss das
mit Daily Driver, mit
Tagesfahrer,
übersetzen. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
die Beschreibung auf Deutsch übersetzt werden
muss. Man weiß es nicht so genau, aber
merkt euch, als Tagesfahrer eignet sich
Windows ME nicht. Da wär ich aber auch so
nicht draufgekommen. Also,
wo haben wir denn hier unser ISO?
Musik ist mir schon wieder zu relaxing, Alter.
Egal, lassen wir jetzt.
Wo haben wir denn die CD? Use
ISO Image. Ließ sich
der Kram damals installieren ohne
CD-Key, dass man sagen konnte, ich aktiviere
später? Ne, ich glaub, das ging nicht. Da muss man
bei der Installation, musste
man zwangsläufig einen CD-Key
eingeben. So, Boot, Moment,
Moment, Moment. Boot from Harddisk? Nein,
ganz bestimmt nicht.
Stretch? Excellent.
Moment, hab ich jetzt gesagt, Stretch
Keep Aspect Ratio?
So rum. So.
Also, Boot from CD.
Was haben wir denn zur Auswahl? Start
Windows Setup, Start Computer mit
CD-ROM Support, Start Computer
ohne CD-ROM. Ich würde sagen, Start
Windows Setup from CD-ROM.
Wahrscheinlich hängt's jetzt und es geht einfach
gar nicht weiter.
Funst.
Dieses blaue Setup-Ding,
das hatten die gefühlt auch 30
Jahre, oder?
Was macht denn F5?
Äh.
Jetzt hab ich die Color removed. Und weiter?
Okay, man kann nur die Color
removen. Die Color wieder einschalten
geht nicht.
Das ist auch Microsoft-Logik, ey.
Ich drücke jetzt weiter F5 und es geht nicht mehr
an.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich Exit mache? Dann startet er
wahrscheinlich einfach neu, hä?
Moment, was?
Press F3. Oh!
Aber Moment, Moment.
Wir sind unter DOS, Alter.
Massive.
DOS-Prompt.
Da muss man jetzt einfach Setup machen.
Ja, Setup.
Äh. Okay.
Reboot?
Shutdown?
Ähm. Check. Ich weiß, ich
weiß, ich kann's einfach über die VM neu starten.
Wie würde man denn jetzt
normalerweise ein DOS
rebooten?
Weiß das irgendjemand von euch noch?
Also es ist weder Reboot
noch
äh.
How to reboot DOS.
Ja.
Super. Auf die Idee wär ich auch gekommen.
Über die VM neu starten. You can use Shutdown.
Haben die doch Shutdown hier.
Shut? Shut.
Okay, scheiß drauf. Windows. Komm, burscht.
Send Control. Alt entfernen.
Gut ist. Boot. Boot from CD.
Start Windows Setup.
Ja, so moderne Sachen
wie ein Reboot-Kommand, das gab's nicht.
Also die Musik ist mir auch
zu, zu
relaxing.
Haben wir denn noch irgendwas, irgendwas was heute dazu?
Holiday Nintendo Tunes.
Okay. Excellent.
Excellent.
Das heißt aber, dass es ein bisschen was weihnachtlich ist.
So. Okay. Setup Windows.
Press Enter.
Repressen. Enter.
Unallocated Disk Space
Recommended.
Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich sag, nein?
Das sagt er wahrscheinlich, das geht nicht.
Ja. Okay.
Es macht jetzt relativ wenig Sinn.
Okay.
You have a drive over 5...
Oh. Oh. High-End-Rechner, Leute.
Über 512 MB Festplatte.
Was war die kleinste Festplatte,
die ihr jemals hattet, Leute?
Ich meine, wirklich in den Händen hattet,
nicht benutzt habt.
Die kleinste Festplatte, die ihr je in den Fingern hattet.
16 MB? Okay.
32 MB.
Ja, bei mir war es auch so in dem Dreh.
Ich glaube, meine war 10, aber ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob es 10 überhaupt gab.
Deswegen vermute ich auch mal 16.
Das war so ein richtig olles, fettes
IBM-Ding.
Das war so ein Backstein.
Das war ein richtig dicker Backstein, die Festplatte.
Was er möchte von uns,
dass wir...
Large-Disk-Support-Enabeln.
Das muss aber nicht so sein,
wie Enable Large-Disk-Support.
Und die kleinste Festplatte,
die ich je benutzt habe,
die müsste wahrscheinlich 0,8 GB gewesen sein.
Mein allererster PC?
Oder hatte der noch weniger?
Ich glaube, der hatte...
0,8 GB.
Oder sogar 1,2 GB schon.
Weil ich kann mich erinnern damals,
wir haben den Rechner gekauft
mit 8 MB RAM
und ich glaube 0,8 GB Disk.
Und als wir den Rechner dann eingeschaltet haben,
waren es 16 MB RAM
und 1,2 GB Disk.
Die haben uns quasi den Rechner,
die Nummer zu groß gegeben.
Dann haben die sich vertan.
Dann haben wir uns natürlich gefreut
und dann haben wir uns gefragt,
warum rebootet der jetzt, um Large Disk Support einzuschalten?
Und vor allem, woher weiß er nach dem Reboot noch,
dass Large Disk Support eingeschaltet ist?
Muss ich jetzt von der Festplatte booten
oder von CD?
Mal gucken, was passiert,
wenn ich von Festplatte booten?
Nichts.
Nice.
Wieder von CD.
Ja, ich dachte auch von...
Ich hätte jetzt auch gedacht von der Festplatte,
aber...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
So einfach ist das in der Microsoft-Logik nicht.
Kann ich einfach jetzt von Festplatte...
Siehste? Easy.
Jetzt wird einfach ohne Rückfrage
BAM, C formatiert.
So muss das sein.
Wisst ihr, bei jedem Scheiß kommt irgendeine Abfrage.
Wollen sie jetzt nicht vielleicht exiten?
Wollen sie jetzt nicht vielleicht zurück?
Aber beim Festplattenformatieren,
also da, wo es tatsächlich mal sinnvoll wäre,
eine Abfrage zu machen...
Nein, das ist einfach
reboot, BAM, Festplatte überschrieben.
Wobei überschrieben,
es ist ja nicht überschrieben.
Das ist ja einfach nur Quick-Format gewesen,
ohne zu überschreiben.
Aber das ist...
Ich hatte damals schon immer das Gefühl,
dass...
Das wirkte auch schon während der Installation
alles super fragil irgendwie.
Windows-Dreck und Trommel.
So, next.
C-Doppelpunkt Windows.
Recommended.
Mir war nicht bewusst,
dass ich das überhaupt irgendwo anders hinmachen könnte.
Und vor allem,
warum möchte man sein Windows-Verzeichnis
irgendwo anders hinmachen?
Next.
Das war wahrscheinlich echt eine ganz blöde Idee,
das woanders hinzumachen.
Es gab bestimmt genug Programme,
die das hardcoded drinnen hatten,
C-Doppelpunkt Windows.
Setup will take 30 zu 60 Minutes.
Die...
Das ging jetzt instant erstmal runter.
Aber die...
Also ich tippe,
die Installation dauert zwei Minuten am Ende.
Ja.
Windows XP habe ich...
Also ich habe tatsächlich Windows XP
und vor allem Windows 98.
Habe ich so oft neu installiert.
Ich konnte damals mein Windows...
Das ist ungelogen, Leute.
Ohne Spaß, wie der Asitoni gesagt hätte.
Ich konnte meinen Windows-CD-Key auswendig.
Noch irgendwelche Windows-CD-Key-Enjoyers hier,
die das...
Also ich habe so oft mein Windows neu installiert.
Ich wusste meinen Windows-CD-Key komplett auswendig.
Ich konnte das blind eintippen.
So oft habe ich neu installiert.
Waren das nicht...
Waren das nicht die geleakten Keys,
die so angefangen haben?
Ja.
FFC-KGW.
Die Super-Legit-Keys.
Haben die nicht so angefangen?
Und ihr wisst ja,
das allererste, was man gemacht hat...
Oder Chat-Gil.
Chat-Gil.
Ich weiß, man macht sowas heute nicht mehr.
Aber damals, als man sich da noch zusammen getroffen hat
und entweder noch per BNC-Kabel
oder schon, wenn man ein bisschen moderner war,
hatte man dann einen Switch und Aeon 45-Stecker
und Netzwerkkarten und sowas.
Als man sich da zusammengestürzt
und gespöpselt hat.
Damals hat man dann so Sachen wie
Half-Life 1-Multiplayer und sowas gespielt.
Es ging aber immer irgendwas nicht.
Immer ging irgendwas nicht.
Und was war die erste Reaktion da drauf,
wenn etwas nicht ging?
Ihr werdet euch jetzt nach der Einleitung
schon denken können,
aber vielleicht kennen das die ein oder andere noch von euch.
Was war das Erste, was man...
Richtig.
Das allererste, was man gemacht hat, ist...
Erstmal rechnen...
Reboot...
Nee, ja, auch.
Auch mehrfach.
Aber das Erste, was man immer gemacht hat,
erst mal die ersten paar Stunden Windows neu installiert.
Immer Windows neu installiert.
Jedes Mal.
Das haben alle erst am Anfang Windows neu installiert.
Und du musstest dann damals in die Windows-Settings...
Wobei, das zeige ich euch.
Das zeige ich euch gleich.
Lasst uns das mal merken.
Okay, also.
Custom.
Was gibt es hier alles dabei?
Das brauchen wir unbedingt.
Ganz wichtig.
Briefcase.
Absolut keine Ahnung, was wir damit machen.
Okay.
Desktop-Wallpapers.
Ganz wichtig.
Mouse-Pointers.
Excellent.
Also, wie soll ich denn ohne...
Guck mal.
Und die brauchen noch 0,0 MB Speicherplatz.
Und der Calculator.
Das ist auch am Start.
Address-Book.
Communications.
Dial-Up-Networking.
Dial-Up-Server.
Was?
Ach, da konnten sich andere in einem Modem auf deinem Windows-95-Zeug einwählen.
Boah, das ist ja super abgedreht gewesen.
Hyper-Terminal.
Ja.
Das war das.
War das sowas wie Telnet?
Was, da war noch mehr beim ersten Punkt?
Wie war noch mehr hier?
Oh, da fehlt...
7 von 8 selected.
Ach, da geht's...
Screensaver.
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Additional Screensavers.
Essentiell.
Komplett essential.
Hyper-Terminal.
War das sowas wie Telnet?
Direct-Cable-Connection.
Nice.
Das war 0 Modem-Kabel.
Okay.
Internet-Connection-Sharing.
Da ist es doch manchmal eine ICS, Leute.
ICS.
MSN-Messenger-Service.
Natürlich, den brauchen wir unbedingt.
Net-Meeting.
Net-Meeting, Alter.
Wisst ihr, dass Net-Meeting...
Das Programm war, wo ich zum allerersten Mal in meinem Leben Booba gesehen hab?
Ja, ich weiß, Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg.
Ähm, Net-Meeting ist so ein bisschen...
Net-Meeting ist ein bisschen der Vorgänger von Teams, so kann man sich das vorstellen.
Oder eher von Skype.
Eher von Skype.
Ja, da konnte man damals online telefonieren mit Webcam und alles.
Und es gab damals schon Seiten mit, ähm, ja, irgendwelchen Porn-Geschichten.
Das war aber damals noch ein bisschen anders.
Das funktionierte damals so.
Du hattest online, also du konntest dich connecten dahin.
Und hab ich natürlich mit einem Freund aus der Schule, nach der Schule, hab ich das da gemacht.
Net-Meeting auf, sie irgendwohin connectet oder so.
Und da hast du dann im Prinzip irgendwelche Mails gehabt, so mit 200x200 Bild und 2 FPS und sowas.
Gab's damals schon, Leute.
Glaubt mir, das ist älter, als ihr denkt, ja, dass es sowas schon gibt.
Und das Ding war halt, die konnten das damals nicht darüber abrechnen.
Und da konntest du dann quasi sagen, äh, boah, hier, äh, ich bin so heiß auf dich oder so, keine Ahnung.
Und dann, und dann hat die dann geantwortet mit, äh, ja, dann ruf doch die 0190 Nummer an, dann kannst du mit mir telefonieren und sowas.
Das war richtig, das war eigentlich super krasser Scam, ja.
Wir haben natürlich nicht angerufen, ganz so blöd waren wir nicht.
Aber wir haben dann immer versucht, über diese, gab's halt so Listen mit Sachen, wo du dich verbinden kannst zu Net-Meeting.
Äh.
Irgendwie, da, irgendwie, noch was zu erhaschen, was man gesehen hat, ja.
Net-Meeting, Mann, meine Güte.
Damals waren wir wahrscheinlich so, lass mal überlegen.
Ich bin 1984 geboren, da war ich wahrscheinlich 15 oder sowas, ja.
14, 15, ja, da probiert man so Dinge aus, ne.
Universal Plug & Play, unbedingt.
VPN, auch ganz wichtig.
Brauchen wir unbedingt alles, alles drauf.
Desktop-Themes.
Alles.
Warum ist Communications immer noch nicht alles an?
Achso.
Games.
Multi-Language-Support.
Ah ja, krieg ich das vielleicht dann auch in Deutsch?
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Es gibt nur Baltic, Central European, Albanisch, Tschechisch, Kroatisch, gibt's, gibt's vielleicht nicht, gibt's vielleicht auch Deutsch?
Weil die, die Microsoft-Übersetzungen waren immer schon, waren schon immer ganz besonders toll auf Deutsch damals.
Die Millenniums-Edition.
Ok, gibt's nicht.
Vielleicht, vielleicht ist das auch so.
Das ist aber auch standardmäßig mit dabei.
Die, was die Beschreibung war, VPN?
Moment, wo?
Wo?
Oh, das ist so, so laggy, die Maus hier drinnen.
Virtual Private Networking.
Provides secure connections to private networks across public networks, networks such as the Internet.
Wieso ist das doch richtig?
Ist doch vollkommen ok, was da steht.
Ich mein, immerhin haben sie, taucht das Wort Internet schon auf.
Oh ja, Multimedia.
Ja.
Multimedia-Shockwave-Flash.
Ganz wichtig.
Multimedia-Sound, Sound-Sample, Sound-Recorder, alles.
Media-Player.
Gib ihm alles drauf.
Online-Services.
Prodigy-Internet.
Earth-Link.
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
AT&T kennt man.
AOL.
Kennt man auch.
Nicht das.
Sag mal, es gibt doch heute bestimmt noch immer noch Dial-Up-Internet, oder?
Ich müsste...
Ich müsste mal echt probieren, ob man...
Ich hab noch mein altes 56K-Modem hier.
Ob man ernsthaft heute noch ein Dial-Up-Modem machen kann?
Clipboard-Viewer.
Compress, Foulness, Network, Assist-Monitor, alles an.
Alles an.
Web-TV für Windows.
Installs Web...
Oh, das ist ein richtig krasses neues Feature.
Das kenn ich nicht.
Web-TV für Windows.
Das funktioniert bestimmt immer noch 30 Jahre später.
Ganz toll.
Next.
Computer-Name.
Kekwe.
Workgroup.
Juckt eh keinen.
Select-Language.
German.
Ich will...
Leute, ich will mir mal die richtig...
Die beste Microsoft-Übersetzung, die es gibt.
German.
Select-Country-Region.
Hören wir mal auch Germany.
Uganda.
Über...
Alter!
Die Technologie ist einfach nicht da heutzutage.
Wo ist...
Wisst ihr, dass das beim aktuellen Windows-Setup nicht funktioniert?
Dass ihr hier unten irgendwo seid, in der Liste, und den Startbuchstaben drückt, und dann springt er da hin?
Das geht im aktuellen Windows-Setup nicht mehr.
Germany.
Select your Keyboard-Layout.
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Keyboard-Layout ist...
German-Standard.
Und Zeitzone ist...
Berlin.
Next.
23 Minuten dauert's jetzt.
Es ging ganz schön schnell, die Zeit von 60 runter auf 23.
Finish.
Windows just got better.
Das ist so schnell, das können wir gar nicht lesen.
Hundreds of enhancements and new features.
Features based on customer requests and product support experiences.
Cutting-edge technology.
Best support for your current hardware.
And programs.
Gut, kann man sich jetzt drüber lustig machen, ist aber Blödsinn.
Ich meine, das ist halt 30 Jahre alt.
Aber cutting-edge.
Connects you to the web.
Das werden wir gleich sehen.
Gleich machen wir den Internet Explorer auf.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich auch erstmal noch TCP, IP und DHCP und so einschalten,
dass ich überhaupt eine IP kriege.
Cutting-edge technology.
Windows Media Player 7.
Windows, ich hab immer noch das Gefühl, 21 Minuten wirst du nicht brauchen, bis du installiert hast.
Improved.
Alter, das geht.
So schnell, das kannst du echt nicht lesen, man.
Easy to update.
Web-based updating.
Na, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, web-based updating.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Guck mal, er denkt immer noch, dass es 21 Minuten dauert.
Register your copy.
Ah, okay.
Sorry, Leute.
20 Minuten.
Eindeutig.
Mit dem Restart sind es nur noch 20 Minuten.
Logisch.
Obviously.
Das hängt.
Leute, ich mach lieber nix.
Finger weg.
Das wirkte damals schon.
Ach, jetzt sind es übrigens nur noch 10 Minuten.
Das wirkte damals schon so super krass fragil auch schon während der Installation, man.
Ich hatte immer Schiss, dass es hängen bleibt.
Kann sich auch noch einer dran erinnern?
Die Windows-Installation war ja auch damals ein bisschen wählerig.
Die blieb manchmal hängen.
Und der hatte einfach nix mehr gemacht.
Dann musstest du neu starten.
Irgendwann ging's dann wieder.
Ich hatte immer Schiss, dass der während der Installation hängen blieb.
Du hattest ja auch keine Möglichkeit rauszubekommen, woran es liegt, dass der hängen bleibt.
Ich hatte so oft, dass es einfach random hängen geblieben ist während der Installation.
Und es hing dann halt.
Hat nichts weiter gemacht.
Okay, non-plug-and-play-Hardware wird detected.
Ist ME die private Version von 2000?
Nee.
Windows ME ist das letzte Windows, quasi DOS-Windows, was es gegeben hat.
Also quasi das letzte der originalen Windows-Linie.
Windows 2000 ist Windows NT-Linie gewesen.
Also sprich, mit Windows ME war dann Schluss.
Ich meine, es war ja im Prinzip Windows 1.
Ob es Windows 2 gab, bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher.
Windows 1, Windows 3, Windows 3.11, Windows 95, Windows 98, Windows ME.
So, und bei den anderen hattest du, glaube ich, Windows NT 3.5, 3.5.1, NT 4 und dann Windows 2000.
Glaube ich.
Bin ich ganz, nicht ganz sicher.
So, Company.
Next.
Oh, Chatge.
Chatge.
Ich will es jetzt nicht leaken.
Ihr müsst mal weggucken kurz, okay?
Ich meine, in der heutigen Zeit interessiert es wahrscheinlich wirklich kein Mensch mehr.
Aber man weiß ja nie.
Man weiß, man weiß ja nie.
Ich tippe jetzt mal kurz schnell ein.
Hoffentlich habe ich...
Oh, nice.
Der hat sogar deutsche Tastatur-Layout.
Ich soll...
Leute.
Wisst ihr was?
Das ist auch was, was unter Windows 11 nicht funktioniert.
Wenn du unter Windows 11 in der Installation deutsches Tastatur-Layout auswählst,
dann musst du nochmal deutsches Tastatur-Layout nach der Installation auswählen.
So.
Da sind wir wieder.
Completed.
Ja, und keine Keys im Chat.
Sonst Mod-Check.
Und jetzt?
Ah, Restart.
Zehn Minuten immer noch, Leute.
Boah, die Maus.
Alter.
Die Maus leckt so krass da drin rum.
Okay.
Er ist wieder am Start.
Ah, er muss ja noch meine Hardware upsetten.
Alles klar.
Setup.
Nicht upsetten.
Windows is now set.
Okay, let's go.
Windows, mach einfach.
Gib ihm.
Seht ihr immer noch?
Die alten, äh, Dateifahne mit über acht Zeichen und so, mit, mit Tilde und so drin.
Das sind auch so die DOS-Überbleibsel.
Updating System Settings.
Component Progress.
Overall Progress.
Okay, das ist wirklich langsamer, als ich dachte.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das alles durch, ja, Single, Single Threading und vielen Sleeps beschränkt.
Die haben, die sind, das Windows-Installationsding, das besteht bestimmt zur Hälfte aus Sleeps.
Dass sie auch sicher sind, dass was fertig ist und sowas.
Das hat bestimmt...
Und Race Conditions ohne Ende.
Und das haben sie alles mit Sleeps gefixt.
War da nicht noch FAT drunter?
Klar, FAT 32 ist das jetzt.
Können wir gleich mal gucken, was ich für ein Dateisystem hab.
Boah, das, das ist wirklich langsamer, als ich gedacht hab.
Aber jetzt, nur noch sieben Minuten.
Die Windows-10-Installation geht schneller.
Ich glaube, es nimmt sich gar nicht mal so viel.
Windows, Windows-10 und Windows-11, die faken auch viel rum mit.
Es lädt jetzt einen neuen Bildschirm und das überbrückt dann wieder zwei Minuten und sowas.
Aber...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist 230-Bit.
Aber du konntest ohne Probleme 16-Bit-Programme ausführen.
Ich find's auch toll, dass er gar nicht so wirklich anzeigt, was er eigentlich macht.
Updating System Settings, Component Progress, Overall Progress.
Man hat ehrlich gesagt...
Guck mal, diese Progress-Bars, die sind komplett unsinnig, weil du überhaupt nicht weißt, was er macht.
Also was ist der Sinn davon, dass es hier überhaupt durchgeht?
Durchläuft.
Willst du jetzt zählen, bei wieviel mal durchlaufender er ist, oder wie?
Aber Microsoft liebt halt einfach Progress-Bars.
Das haben wir schon oft an vielen Stellen gesehen.
Warum eigentlich? Das weiß ich nicht, warum.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die gelernt haben, dass die Leute sonst Angst haben, wenn sich nicht permanent was bewegt, dass es kaputt ist.
Und die Angst war ja damals auch berechtigt, dass was kaputt ist.
Wie oft mir das Windows-Setup einfach random hängen geblieben ist.
Okay, so sah also der Login-Bildschirm aus.
Da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal schauen, dass es überhaupt noch Veränder-Tools gibt.
Und?
Da sind wir!
Wir testen nicht Windows ME.
Testen kann man das nicht.
Okay, hier kann man nichts umstellen.
Also Veränder-Tools jetzt.
Die Ladetrommel.
Wisst ihr, ich hab damals immer gedacht, wenn man eine Soundkarte hätte, dann würde man das Trommeln hören.
Was aber Blödsinn ist, es trommelt nie.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal schauen.
Install for MWare-Tools.
Präge, dass das funktioniert.
Woop, woop, Instant!
WebTV für Windows.
Okay, das wollen wir uns gleich angucken.
Ja, äh, was gibt's denn da zur Auswahl?
Okay, typisch ist alles. Nice.
Sehr gutes Installationsprogramm vor MWare.
Yes.
Äh, Blue Screen.
Hahaha.
An Eject Request was received for a drive that is in use.
Continue with- Moment, hab ich nicht eingestellt, dass ich es auf Deutsch benutzen will?
Chatge, ich hab doch ausgewählt, dass ich es auf Deutsch haben will.
Gibt's nicht.
Ja, damals wurde prinzipiell alles autorunned, was eingelegt wurde.
Okay.
Habt ihr's gehört?
Es hat einen Sound gemacht.
Yes.
Es hat gemacht D.
Hat's gemacht D.
Und wir haben Farben!
Yep, Clock!
Und auch den Login-Sound.
Okay.
Settings. Was für Auflösung haben wir denn zu bieten?
Vor MWare macht hier nix.
Haben wir tau-
Ah, fuck!
Wir haben kein 1920x1080?
Können wir denn vielleicht mit irgendeinem gefakten Monitor dazu überreden, das zu machen?
Gnancy Star Compliant? Natürlich...
Was sonst?
Custom-Auflösung ging damals noch nicht, gell?
Ah, vielleicht gibt's hier was mit
Ich wusste genau, dass das ein Problem ist.
Das wusste ich schon von Windows 98.
Und ich hab mir schon was rausgesucht!
mir schon was rausgesucht ob es funktioniert weiß ich allerdings nicht und zwar was würden
wir ohne reddit machen für display auflösung so und laut einem reddit post den ich gefunden
habe müssen wir unter hk current config display settings resolution und da kann man 1920 ups wenn
man das ist so richtig schreibt mal 1080 reinschreiben und jetzt soll angeblich rock
excellent das ist messer kogas full hd ohne hd aber mal gucken ob das nach dem reboot immer noch
full hd ist erst mal gucken ob das nach dem reboot immer noch full hd ist
Ist es, ist es.
Fullest HD.
Oh, Gers, Alter.
So, jetzt lasst uns mal was kurz gucken.
Update.
Windows Update.
Das geht im Leben nicht mehr.
100%.
Wenn das noch gehen würde, das glaube ich nicht.
Oh.
Thank you for your interest in Windows Update.
To take it...
Moment.
Wir haben keine Connections to the Internet.
Was ist da los?
Moment, Moment.
CMD?
Nee.
Muss man damals noch Excel eingeben?
Fuck.
Wie hat man damals den Terminal aufgemacht?
Accessories?
System Tools?
Oh, no.
Gab es nicht hier einen DOS...
Ah, hier.
MS-DOS-Prompt.
Da ist es doch.
Gab es damals schon IP-Config?
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Sind wir nicht connected to the Internet?
Doch.
Wir sind mit dem Internet connected.
Steht genau da.
Wir sind mit...
Guck.
Wir können Google DNS pingen.
Wir sind mit dem Internet connected.
Connect...
Ah, ja.
Connect me to the Internet.
Okay, dead.
Hätte mich jetzt auch echt gewundert, wenn das irgendwie funktioniert hätte.
Google.de.
Wow.
Was jetzt?
Welcome to MSN Internet Access.
Wir müssen ein Modem installieren, bevor wir weitergehen.
Ein Modem?
Warte mal.
Ich...
Ich hab kein Modem.
Ähm...
LAN.
Manual.
Connect using my local area network.
Massive.
Discovery Proxy.
Jawohl.
Do you want to set up an Internet Mail Account?
Nein, nein, nein.
Lass gut sein, Microsoft.
Finish.
Und jetzt?
Detect Proxy Settings.
Also wir sind mit dem Internet verbunden.
Okay, Google.
Mein Browser hängt.
Leute!
Google ist...
Sowas von rückwärtskompatibel noch, dass es einfach funktioniert im Internet Explorer.
Und welcher Internet Explorer ist das?
Internet Explorer 5.5.
Snapshot?
Du meinst hiervon?
Bevor wir es kaputt machen.
Ja, guckt mal da.
Gmail.
Das können wir doch im Leben hin.
You are about to view pages over a secure connection.
Warum?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Warum war es ein Security Alert, wenn die Sache jetzt besser ist?
Oh, Gmail geht nicht.
Ja, das ist klar, ne?
Kek weh, Alter.
Ey.
Yes.
Immerhin.
Google funktioniert noch.
Google funktioniert.
Funktioniert noch.
Kek weh zeigt ein stärkeres Lachen an als vergleichbare Begriffe wie LOL oder Haha.
Okay, Google ist super krass rückwärtskompatibel.
Oh nein.
Schon wieder Postleitzahl-Leak.
Und ich wohne wahrscheinlich immer noch mitten im Main, wenn wir auf Google Maps gehen.
An den Maps geht natürlich hier drin nichts.
Das ist schon mal klar.
So, meinen YouTube-Punkt müssen wir alle ausprobieren.
So, aber was ich...
Stimmt, wir wollten folgendes gucken.
Ob das FAT32 war, habt ihr gefragt.
Das ist FAT32.
Oh yeah.
Massive Cleanup.
Bup.
Oh.
Tools.
Oh, die Fest...
Jawoll, Leute.
Die Festplatte wird defragmentiert.
Wie lange habe ich schon keine Festplatten-Defragmentierung mehr gesehen, ey?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, das verwirrt die SSD.
Unglaublich unten drunter.
Also, das wird wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktionieren.
Aber man könnte die Festplatte defragmentieren.
Guck hier.
Guck mal, hier wird richtig hart rum defragmentiert.
Massive Defragmentierer.
Bup.
Do you want to quit disk...
Was ist, wenn ich sage no?
Bleibt einfach auf.
Unsinniger Dialog.
Checkdisk.
Ah, das macht keiner...
Uncensored.
Okay.
Tune-up.
Boah, ey.
So ein Schrott habe ich nie verwendet.
Warum genau?
Warum genau startet mein Control Panel nicht?
Was ist das Problem?
Bitte schön.
Control Panel wurde defragmentiert.
G-Folder.
Is null or not an object?
Okay.
Yes.
Das sieht man mal.
Das Zeug lief damals schon extrem gut, ne?
Ja.
Internet Explorer Script Error.
Okay, da müssen wir jetzt mal danach suchen.
Internet Explorer Scripts Error Control Panel.
Okay, geil.
Wir müssen...
Das war anscheinend damals schon ein Browser.
Kann man wenigstens hier in die Settings gehen?
Fuck, Alter, mein Control Panel ist kaputt.
Und jetzt?
Aber das funktioniert und sowas hier.
References?
Leute, wir machen das...
Das ging aber eben.
Wir machen das, was immer hilft unter Windows.
Restart.
Kann es sein, dass die Defragmentierung das kaputt gemacht hat?
Die Defragmentierung hat mein Windows zerstört.
Aber zum Glück, Chat, sehr gute Idee gewesen von euch.
Zum Glück haben wir einen Snapshot.
Das war doch vor der Defragmentierung, oder?
Ah.
Du konntest nichts klicken.
Jetzt war nichts mehr anklickbar.
Es funktioniert.
Also, merke, Defragmentierung ist eine äußerst dumme Idee.
Unter Windows ME in der VM auf SSD.
Ah ja, wir müssen...
Selbstverständlich.
Moment, Leute.
Ich muss...
Ich muss Dings installieren.
Ähm.
Avira, Leute.
Gibt es Avira noch für Windows ME?
Naja.
Aber ich wollte euch ja eigentlich was zeigen.
Ähm.
Das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Free Hotmail.
Naja, das tut alles nicht mehr.
Das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gebracht, dass mein Windows einfach kaputt gegangen ist.
Ähm.
Ich wollte euch ja was zeigen.
Und zwar...
Wir hatten es ja ursprünglich davon, dass, wenn man sich zusammengesetzt hat,
das erste, was man gemacht hat, also mit mehreren Leuten damals zusammen Half-Life 1 lokal Multiplayer oder so spielen wollte,
oder teilweise sogar Internet-Connection-Sharing machen wollte,
das ging übrigens so irgendwie.
Ähm.
Internet-Connection-Sharing?
Boah, Fuck.
Das kriege ich noch mal zusammen, wie das funktioniert.
Da konnte man ja zumindest jetzt drüber ins Internet.
Zumindest...
Was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte, ist hier.
Du musstest damals, damit die ganzen Spiele lokal noch funktioniert haben,
musstest du erstmal hier, man kann das übrigens auch nicht resizen oder sowas,
musstest du erstmal hier reingehen,
dann erstmal in...
Das sieht irgendwie so komisch aus.
TV-Adapter?
Internet-Connection-Sharing?
Okay.
Zumindest, du musstest dann da reingehen
und irgendwo, wenn du Glück hattest,
hast du dann dein...
deine Netzwerkkarte gefunden?
Nee.
Wo konnte ich jetzt überhaupt meine IP-Adresse einstellen?
Ah, hier.
Genau.
So, und dann musstest du erstmal unter...
Bindings?
NetBIOS, genau.
Du musstest erstmal NetBIOS enablen,
was standardmäßig nicht enabelt war,
dass manche Spiele im Multiplayer funktiert haben.
Dann musstest du noch IPX,
IPX-SPX hinzufügen.
IPX-SPX.
Dann musstest du noch
NetBOI hinzufügen.
So, und dann...
konnte man, glaube ich, diesen ganzen Krempel
auch noch, musste man auch manchmal noch irgendwas einstellen.
Was habe ich denn jetzt hinzugefügt?
ATM-Call-Manager, das wollte ich gar nicht.
Was auch immer.
Besser als NetPlayer, ja, das stimmt voll.
So, und dann...
Das hast du beispielsweise damals für den Half-Life-1-Multiplayer gebraucht.
IPX oder...
Ich bilde mir sogar einen noch für Quake 3.
Oder vielleicht da auch schon nicht mehr.
Zumindest IPX, IPX-SPX.
NetBOI.
Und man musste sicherstellen, dass hier...
Ich weiß nicht, warum das jetzt gar...
Warum man das nicht mehr einstellen kann.
Man musste einstellen, dass man NetBIOS...
over TCP-IP enablen möchte.
Das war wichtig dafür.
Chatge, wer von euch weiß, wofür das wichtig ist,
dass man NetBIOS über TCP-IP aktiviert?
Vielleicht ist einer von euch noch Fivehead
und kann sich da noch dran erinnern und weiß das noch.
Ach so, Restart.
Selbstverständlich, obviously, muss restartet werden danach.
Weil UDP-Standard war.
Nee, nee, nee, das war nicht das Problem.
Du musstest das machen, weil...
Oh, guck mal.
Jetzt kriegen wir sogar ein neues Login.
Enter password for Microsoft networking.
Sind wieder da.
Du musstest das machen, weil sonst die Netzwerkumgebung nicht funktioniert hat.
Entire network. Unable to browse network.
This may be for a number of reasons.
Oh.
Windows ist gecrashed.
Shit.
Oder nicht?
Oder doch?
Fuck.
Nee.
Doch nicht.
RitterRost, danke für den Zap.
Also, man muss...
Man musste...
Yes.
Do you use the Internet on this computer?
A direct connection to my IP...
Ja, genau, ja, ja.
Yes.
My computer...
Use the default network to MS Home.
Okay.
Share.
Nein.
Yes, create a home networking setup disk.
No.
Restart.
Natürlich.
Du musstest damals echt wegen jedem Scheiß restarten, Mann.
Hauptsache restart, Mann.
Komm, jetzt brauchst du auch viel länger zum Restarten.
Congratulations.
Home networking is set up on this computer.
Now run the home networking wizard on your other home computers.
Ja.
Okay, das geht immer noch nicht.
Siehste?
Das war echt so ein Ding.
Alter.
Damit...
Damit dieses Netzwerk anzeigen funktioniert hat, da musstest du noch irgendwelche Magic-Sachen
hier enablen.
Aber ich weiß, ich weiß nicht mehr was, ehrlich gesagt.
Wisst ihr was wir mal ausprobieren könnten?
So, mal neuer Ordner.
Share.
Konnte man hier schon...
Man konnte doch unter Windows ME schon Windows Shares machen irgendwie.
Aber so, aber so ging das anscheinend damals noch nicht.
Wie konnte man damals?
File and print sharing.
I want to be able to give other access to my files.
Yes, will ich.
Restart, pass auf, restart, restart.
Restart kommt jetzt.
Restart.
Das wird mich...
Willenlos, Alter.
Restart.
Oh, haben wir es gebraked?
Oh, shit.
Nee.
Okay.
Nochmal Glück gehabt.
Ich habe schon gedacht, es ist kaputt.
Das hat einen so fragilen Eindruck schon gemacht.
Was, beim Standardrechner kann man auch auf Cancel drücken?
Das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht.
Geil, Alter.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Man kann ernsthaft auf Cancel drücken und das Kind lockt dich trotzdem ein.
Das ist ja geil, Mann.
So, kann ich jetzt meinen Ordner sharen?
Oh, guck mal hier.
Share as, wait, full access, full access password.
Okay.
Mal gucken.
Ich bin jetzt echt gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Wartet mal, Leute.
Command, IP-Config.
Hier, die brauchen wir mal kurz.
Lass mal gucken, ob das noch von meinem modernen Windows-Windows-Stells funktioniert hier.
Ja.
2, 1, 7, Punkt 1, 3, 5.
Äh, Windows?
Das hat ja einfach keinen Bock jetzt.
Alter!
2, 1, 7, Punkt 1, 3, 5.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt ein Windows-11-Problem.
Windows-11, kannst du mal aufhören, irgendwie beschissen zu sein?
Ich glaube, da kann man nicht drauf zugreifen.
Ach so, sagen wir mal 1-Support an.
Nee.
Nee, nee, hab ich nicht.
Dann geht das wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Konnte man hier schon sowas eingeben?
Not locked on.
Okay.
Ah!
Moment.
Not locked on?
Muss ich da jetzt?
Ah!
Can't wait!
Übrigens, diese Dinger waren mega unsecure.
Es gibt tausende Cracking-Tools von Windows-Laufwerkshares.
Windows-11 hat die alte Samba-Version nicht mehr drin.
Okay, das ist auch irgendwo sinnvoll, ja.
Das ist nicht...
Das ist nicht mehr aktiviert ist.
Ja, aber hier, cack, cack, cack, wait.
Hier.
Das war mal geshared.
So, das haben wir jetzt ja schon gemacht.
So.
Also, alle...
Allerwichtig.
Wir brauchen...
Moment, Moment.
Appearance.
Wir müssen uns mal diese tollen Windows-Themes angucken, die damals dabei waren.
Boah, wie viele Sachen da dabei waren.
Okay, es sieht eins beschissener aus als das andere.
Wobei man sagen musste, dass man die...
...die...
Die alten Windowses und Windows XP und so, die konnte man echt noch verhältnismäßig gut customizen.
Gerade Windows XP gab es ja jede Menge Theme-Engines und sowas für.
Aber da ist jetzt nichts dabei, was ich verwenden will.
Ah, es gibt die guten...
Da habe ich mich so abgefeiert damals bei diesem Screensafer.
Da habe ich mich so abgefeiert, ey.
Das war für mich so eines der...
Die...
Ja.
Die Zukunft ist jetzt, quasi.
Mei...
Ja.
Und konnte man das nicht Fullscreen machen?
Ist doch...
Hä?
Ey.
Windows.
Jetzt ist es einfach wieder zugegangen.
Ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen crappy war das Ganze ja schon, ne?
Maze.
Settings.
Size.
Ads.
Ah.
Da habe ich mich echt abgefeiert damals.
Die...
Die Zukunft ist angebrochen, dachte ich mir, als ich das gesehen habe.
Wundervoll, ja?
Man sieht vor allem die Wände, die einfach nur ein Pixel dick sind, quasi.
Also null Pixel dick, eigentlich.
Guckt euch die...
Die Kan...
Wow.
Die Kante von den Wänden an.
Die ist halt quasi nur ein...
Oder null...
Null Pixel breit, so.
Naja.
Was haben wir sonst noch Schönes?
Pipes.
Oh.
Den kennt jeder, oder?
Den kennt wirklich jeder.
Oh.
in die ganzen hintergrundbilder kannst ja im prinzip auch was die wallpaper
selected can be shown on the desk only if active desktop ist enabled was zum teufel
ist aber jetzt yes yes active desktop bester jetzt wirkt der desktop gleich
deutlich deutlich aktiver und besser muss man sehen also ich finde der fühlt
sich jetzt gleich komplett anders an active desktop was haben wir denn hier
was ist das denn my current home ist das internet explorer auf dem desktop
oder was das ist ja komplett unsinnig wer will so was dann haben
da kommt man hier gibt es noch windows windows m e als internet explorer
edition customer ist mal das so wie haben wir
noch new desktop item new active ok http google
ja
ok
leute
also immer ich jetzt hier habe
dass das war sie so hat widgets bisschen buggy das ganze vielleicht ja
widgets
das
,
also
ok
jetzt ist es wieder ganz normaler desktop immerhin hat microsoft damals
mitgedacht und hat es einfach mit einem klick disablen lassen also das able bar
machen lassen und nicht dieses schritt will bis zu haibeil sagt oder wenn aus
elb pro sache einfach so sind wie sie sind und falls euch etwas auffällt guckt
mal hier man hat obwohl man obwohl man hier mehrere explorer fenster auf hat
man hat tatsächlich für jedes ding einen eigenen eintrag in der taskleiste ist
ja auch ein ding wo wir die technologie nicht mehr haben unter windows 11 wobei
ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es gibt es das gibt es gab es damals schon diese
neuesten utah wüsten wallpaper ob das da gibt es wüste und cloud leute jeder
der windows 95 hatte hatte dieses ding wenn das 95 enjoy hatten die wolken
damals alle das dumme ist ich sehe die maus nicht wo ist die maus da windows 3
11 vibes aber wir bleiben hierbei viel viel neuer so was haben wir denn so
schönes hier setup msn internet access ja das haben wir schon gemacht das
funktioniert natürlich nicht mehr weg moment ich habe jetzt zwei sachen
gelöscht was habe ich denn zwei sachen gelöscht kann man nicht nur die kauf an
ist weg a new fall da habe ich gelöscht wie genau habe ich es geschafft new
fall dazu löschen
m
Toll
so damals gab es übrigens noch das gute outlook express wenn ihr mich fragt war
das gar kein schlechter e mail klein damals das war minimalistisch und hat
funktioniert ich war mittlerweile kannst du natürlich vergessen aber das was
danach kam diese ganzen versuche fand ich persönlich schlimmer es gab dann
erst windows live mail dann gab es dieses neue mail dann uwe diese wp mail und ich
habe mir sie jetzt aber die mail app okay unfassbar schlecht was was was ist was
es beim aua los dass wir uns irgendwo angeguckt drama drama juf network e mail
ok zeit ist 4 tab returned
write express 5
da gehen das brauche ich natürlich nicht so birn lasst uns was gucken und zwar ich
habe ja gesagt ich wollte mal aus projekten moment jetztлись wir auch noch
gucken nicht dass lüfter drama wieso was ist was gibt es bei top 10 wieuito jeff crossing
was war ich habe auch nichts mitbekommen wie wie bekommt man updates für windows
xp eigentlich
ich hätte gern so ein update package oder sowas da gehe ich bestimmt nicht
hin da gehe ich nicht hin ich will die offiziellen updates
was a little discouraging so hier wie art update windows in me
we can use a tool kit which in this rool als is the city image that contains the
offline installer packages for the individual updates archive.org has us
covered with a very large archive of windows updates for legacy operating
systems okay which spans windows 95 through windows we lost assuming that
you are not on a metered internet connection
wie kinder
Das machen wir jetzt.
Wulos.
Ne, doch Wulos.
Machen wir.
Oh.
Retro System Revival Blogspot.com
Das kann man doch nicht unter Windows öffnen, oder?
We just need to download the unofficial service pack for Windows ME, then install it.
Trau ich mich, das das runterzuladen?
Sounds pretty easy, right?
So, what's the catch?
Like any unofficial service pack, it's unofficial.
Meaning that Microsoft didn't make it.
Among other things, the implications are, the unofficial service pack has not been tested to the degree that Microsoft would have.
Naja, nicht das Microsoft.
Dass Microsoft dafür getestet hätte, oder?
And the unofficial service pack may not be complete.
Similar to filling your car with gas, how do you know the appropriate amount of gas made it into the tank?
It would be very difficult to test and confirm.
The next is that it doesn't feel like the system has been patched.
Through the normal life cycle of the operating system, there would be monthly updates released, which would then need to be installed.
Condensing that process into a single installer package makes...
That makes patching the system feel effortless.
Where do we have to go?
Option 4.
In a previous video, we looked at the auto-patcher for Windows 98.
What we are attempting to do here is take a Windows 98 system that has been fully patched and upgrade it to Windows ME.
Naja, okay, also, wie heißt dieses Ding?
Oh, ich muss mal kurz meine Linux-VM anmachen, ich trau mich da nicht drauf.
Retro?
Wie hieß dieses Ding?
Retro System Revival.
Das klingt ja sehr vertrauenserweckend alles, Mann.
Und Möglichkeit 2 war was?
Wulos.
Okay, das können wir auch mal probieren.
Von archive.org.
Kann man archive.org aufmachen mit Internet Explorer 5?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, hä?
Oh.
Wulos.
Ne.
Wie war das?
Details.
Oh, ah.
Wulos.
Ja, ja, ich bin...
Warte, auch nett.
Kann man hier drinnen suchen?
Search?
Okay, vergiss das mit Windows.
Vergiss das mit Windows.
Das war...
Was ist das?
Warum geht...
Okay, ich muss meine Linux-Kiste aufmachen.
Wie hieß das?
Archive.org.
Wulos.
Ist doch hier...
Windows Updates for Legacy Operating Systems.
Show.
Für Vista?
Ne.
Nein, ich will Windows ME haben.
Nicht 95 und Vista.
Ne, das bringt mir nix.
Okay, dann machen wir das andere.
Retro Revival Blogspot.
Oder wie hieß das?
Retro System Revival Blogspot.
Und dann?
Wo ist der hin?
Easy, right?
So...
Windows ME Service Pack.
Windows ME?
Ah, alles klar.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, wo wir gelandet sind.
Die Weeps sind überall.
Ähm, was bin ich hier sehend?
Service Pack.
Gibt es das hier irgendwie?
System Updates.
ME?
Alter, die findest du ja gar nicht.
Ach hier, Windows ME.
After years of waiting.
A proper service pack with system updates.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das wirklich installieren will, Alter.
Das ist komplett...
Download now.
Mega.
Das ist ja super vertrauenserweckend, wo man hier die Updates herbekommt, Mann.
Chat, ich glaube, ich muss für meine VM mal ganz dringend die Netzwerkverbindung gleich ausschalten, bevor ich das da drauf kopiere, Alter.
Geht eigentlich Copy-Paste in Windows 95 rein?
Alter!
Copy-Paste funktioniert einfach...
Einfach.
Na, einfach.
Nicht.
Jagst durch Virus total durch.
Ja, okay.
Machen wir.
Download now.
Wo komm ich denn hier raus?
Bei den China-Chinesen, Mann.
Download.
Excellent.
Ja.
Virus total.
Choose file.
Download.
Downloads, ja.
Gib ihm.
Scheint sauber zu sein.
Es schlagen bei vier irgendwelche random Heuristik-Checks an.
Also, da ist nichts Wildes drin, denke ich mal.
Wissen tut man es natürlich nicht.
Egal, wir kopieren das jetzt rüber und installieren das.
Easy.
Downloads?
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
Sort.
Moment.
Arrange.
By Modification Date.
Um.
Ume.
Dings.
Okay.
Genau.
Desktop.
Kann man das vielleicht umbenennen?
Nicht in Excel, dass das irgendwie einfach irgendwie Punkt Keckel heißt oder so?
Boah, ja.
Ich kopiere sowas ungern bei mir auf den Rechner drauf, Mann.
So, und jetzt?
Und jetzt muss das Ganze rein kopiert werden.
Ich hoffe, man kann in Windows ME Sachen rein kopieren.
Okay.
Funs.
Nice.
Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Da ist es.
Hier sieht man auch die Extension.
Excel.
This Package is not part from Mac.
Are you sure you wish to?
Yes.
Ups.
Und erst mal wieder alles, erst mal wieder alles löschen.
Ja.
Und erst mal.
Und jetzt, Leute, gleich mal.
Ich bin ja immer paranoid bei sowas.
Erst mal gleich noch.
Prozess Explorer launchen.
Ja.
Genau.
Entschuldigung.
Oh.
Man weiß es nicht.
Tja.
Kriege ich das auf der Weeb-Seite?
Was ist hier unten mit meinem
Vm-Wert-Zeug los?
Gibt es auf der Weeb-Seite?
Äh, Favori, ja genau.
Internet Explorer.
Internet Explorer 6
Download ME.
Chip.
Muss man SP1
inszenieren?
Aha.
Kann man das
hier aufmachen?
Nein, das ist HTTPS.
Das funktioniert natürlich nicht.
Ja.
Ich muss keine Chip...
Ich kriege es ja nicht mal runtergeladen.
Zip.
IE6
SP1. Jawohl.
Gibt es da nicht
irgendeinen offiziellen Download?
Irgendwas? Microsoft?
WinFuture. Genau.
Das brauchen wir.
Das sieht halbwegs...
Halbwegs official aus, Mann.
Download jetzt starten.
Den brauchen wir.
Ja.
IE6 SP1 ME.
Hatte...
Kann Windows ME schon Zip-Dateien entpacken?
Ging das?
Ging das schon?
Werden wir gleich sehen.
Ne?
Fuck.
Warum nicht?
Da brauchen wir WinZip, würde ich sagen.
Musik?
Musik ist aus.
Da brauchen wir WinZip.
Oder...
Oder WinRar.
Alter, Vmware.
Spack doch mal nicht so dumm rum, Alter.
Kack Software, Mann.
Ähm.
Doch.
Windows ME kann schon entpacken.
Guckt hier.
Seht ihr?
Richtig.
Advanced as shit.
Kann Zips entpacken.
IE6 Setup.
Dieser Ordner enthält die benötigten Info...
Kann er gelöscht werden?
Das ist nett, dass ihr...
Ich stimme dem Vertrag zu.
Leute.
Jetzt hat uns Microsoft.
Anwalt ist unterwegs.
Ich stimme dem Vertrag zu.
Sign.
Jetzt sind es ja die typischen Komponenten.
Gib ihm.
Das dauert wahrscheinlich länger.
Finish.
Vielen Dank.
Okay.
Es restartet einfach mal random.
Mit was auch immer für einem Hintergrund.
Was auch immer da abgeht gerade.
Ist es jetzt broken?
Nee.
Es macht noch was.
Es updated System Settings.
Warum habe ich diesen hässlichen Hintergrund die ganze Zeit jetzt da gehabt?
Es ist alles nicht so klar.
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Okay.
Haben wir jetzt Internet Explorer 6 drauf?
Ist das jetzt IE6?
Hey.
Es ist IE6, Leute.
Sieht Google jetzt moderner aus?
Die Suchseite konnte nicht geöffnet werden.
Okay.
Muss ich sagen http://he.google.de?
Nee.
Mein Internet geht nicht mehr.
Ding.
Hm.
Es hat meine Netzwerk-Config zerschossen.
Nice.
Windows Update.
Sehr gut.
Es ging damals schon immer richtig gut alles.
Ach, ich habe vor allem mal disconnected.
Ich kack, Noob.
Ja, ist richtig.
Ist richtig.
Lul.
Was ist da im Hin...
Alter!
What the f...
Windows!
Stimmt.
Ich muss das Netzwerk wieder connecten.
Ihr habt recht.
Ich habe es disconnected.
Ja, korrekt.
Korrekt.
Ich glaube, Windows checkt es nicht im laufenden Betrieb, oder?
Doch.
Erstmal auf Windows schimpfen.
Nee, warte mal ab.
Gehen tut es trotzdem noch nicht so, wie es aussieht.
Die Proxy-Einstellungen werden gesucht.
Hey!
Kack.
Weh.
Nee, es geht genauso wenig wie davor.
Aber...
Aber immerhin.
Hier geht auch nicht mehr.
Also, das Upgrade vom Internet Explorer...
Okay, dann installieren wir jetzt mal das super official Package from Microsoft.
What is included?
Ah, ja.
Ach, die Sachen alle.
Ah, obvious.
Obvious.
Hm.
Jetzt...
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Jetzt verstehe ich alles, wenn ich weiß, dass das hier included ist.
Alles klar.
Let's go.
Ich würde es ja immer noch...
Ich würde es ja immer noch gerne in ein eigenes Netzwerk setzen.
Lasst mich noch mal kurz beim Installieren so wirklich trauen durch dem Zeug hier nicht,
was ich da am Start habe, ne?
Okay.
Unofficial Update.
You must have...
Ja, wir haben IE 6 installiert.
Das da haben wir...
Command Prompt...
Nee.
Paint Graphics Filter.
Updates.
Install Updates for Windows and Internet Explorer.
Klar.
Paint Graphics Filter.
Unbedingt.
Das brauchen wir, glaube ich, eher nicht.
Okay.
Stimmt.
Was für ein Paint haben die da eigentlich dabei?
Ja, das ist das Uralpaint noch.
Der Klassiker.
Was...
Was passiert hier gerade?
Erweitertes Info-Installationsprogramm.
License.
Das erweiterte Info-Installationsprogramm muss Windows neu starten.
Okay.
Was?
Wait.
Wir warten.
Was auch immer...
Was auch immer es tut, was auch immer es macht, oh, mein Windows hängt.
Windows.
Dead.
Dead now.
Okay.
End Task.
Das ist...
Das ist so super fragil alles, man.
Und warum habe ich diesen dummen Hintergrund-Depilter?
Das habe ich doch nie eingestellt.
Warum habe ich diesen komischen Hintergrund-Pilter?
hintergrundbild komisch hintergrundbild so top jetzt haben wir das jetzt haben
wir das update 10 inwieweit ist jetzt was gebracht hat bin ich mir nicht
sicher aber jetzt haben wir das top aktuellste windows xp windows me was wir
haben können was macht die dauerkarriere ich hab den
super krassen kreisel client gemacht die letzten tage
ich habe 4 2 2 alp 50er 2 mit 50 komplett getemplatet mache ich wäre ich
habe die übelsten kreisel client gestartet wo spielst du gerade weil zu
ihnen spielst haben wir mal in gruppe irgendwann in letzter zeit kann das sein
der name kommt mir bekannt vor kann sein mit 50 jetzt musst du erst mal gucken
dass du gescheites equipment an start kriegst und bisschen geld machen
es
a moment es ist ja das ist ja das am anfang hatte ich hier unten so was das
nannte sich windows web tv das ist das ist einfach das ist einfach komplett
verschwunden mittlerweile oder und es ist auch guck mal es ist auch ein
neueres es ist auch ein neueres media player jetzt dabei als am anfang es ist
jetzt media player jetzt ein neueres es ist auch ein neueres media player jetzt
nicht mehr sieben sondern media player das passt hier nicht Garブ инструмент
funktioniert Lasまぁ website einfach in der Sunday
also ich glaube das ist schon jetzt schon das ist schon glaube ich nicht
mal nicht mal 7 das ist glaube ich schon was was neueres was radio tuner wird
von uns bestimmt immer noch als ganz bestimmt ja eigentlich eigentlich wollte
ich ja noch analysieren diesen es sollte ihr default browser nicht tauchen halten kann das ist das normal ambulance ist ein bestand weil es ist halt es ist eine media player nicht mehr sieht sondern media player da funktioniert nichts mann dass entfernt ist einfach neuer jetzt also ich glaube das ist schön das schon das ist glaub ich nicht WAS NEJMEHR nicht mehr sieht das ist 적licht nicht was das dealership ist was radio tuner was radio tuner ja eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich wollte ich ja noch diesen ist not your default browser ist not your default browser ist als dabei wel quicklist ist oder also dass nicht mehr der Urlaub der rick oder Zeμ ist der занимierer von oder Fe marketed er
Would you like to make it your default?
Was ist denn mein Default-Browser?
Wenn nicht Internet Explorer.
No.
Yes.
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt stört er sich nicht mehr drüber.
Ja, ich wollte doch jetzt eigentlich noch Browser-Service ausprobieren.
Das testen wir jetzt kurz noch.
GitHub Browser-Service.
Wir machen auch mal hier einen Snapshot von der Kiste.
Nicht das, was wir brauchen, aber man weiß es ja nie.
Hier, Browser-Service.
Browse the modern web on historical browsers.
Releases.
Wahrscheinlich das App-Image runterladen und starten.
Gucken wir mal.
Ah, da muss ja wieder Netzwerk.
Was?
Ich habe dich gefragt, ob es sein kann, dass wir letztens in der Gruppe waren.
Der Name kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Okay, Downloads.
Gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Wie da wieder ganze Krempel funktioniert.
Browser-Service App-Image.
Wow, what?
Verdana-Font is not installed.
Oh nein.
Run install Verdana.
Okay, wenn der das sagt.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Ich meine, ich habe eh einen Snapshot gemacht.
Ingame-Name ist Pox.
So.
Und jetzt?
Funzt das jetzt?
Äh, Netz-Set minus 8080.
Okay, jetzt.
Okay, funzt.
Nice.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das klappt.
Geht das auch?
Geht das auch mit meiner externen, meiner IP hier?
8080?
Testen wir es mal von Windows aus.
Nein, das listet schon mal nur lokal.
Wie sagt man dem denn?
Ja, das listet auch nur lokal.
Wie sagt man dem denn, wie er listen soll?
Elb?
Achso, ich habe ja keinen T-Max.
Blogbrowser-Font, was?
Ah, hier.
Opt-HTTP-Listen-Port.
Ähm, kann man da so was wie Sternchen vielleicht reinmachen?
Nee.
Oder 0.0.0?
Das ist ja an allem listen.
Ja.
Nice, funzt.
Okay.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das aus der Windows 98 VM funktioniert.
Da bin ich ja mal echt gespannt.
Äh, aus der Windows ME VM.
Gut, dazu müssen wir die Netzwerkverbindung wieder einschalten.
Man, gibt es, gibt es Schlimmeres?
Netzwerkverbindung wieder einschalten.
Internet Explorer aufmachen?
Hä?
Okay, der ist nicht so schnell mit Netzwerkverbindung.
Ja.
Wo ist das?
Ah, das hat er es wieder nicht gecheckt.
Ihr habt doch, ich habe doch gerade die Netzwerkverbindung eingeschaltet, oder?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, wir müssen mal wieder das, das übliche machen.
Was hilft, wenn mal irgendwas nicht geht?
Warum, wo kommt diese hässliche Hintergrundbild hier?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Oh, da hat man jemanden.
Oh, da hat man irgendwas geupdatet, ich weiß nicht mal was.
Aber, aber Hauptsache, er hat irgendwas geupdatet, den Hintergrund.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Ah!
Will now close.
So, pray it, dass Google wieder funzt.
Guck mal, ob Google DNS...
Okay, ja, okay, mein DNS funzt wieder.
Also, theoretisch sollte, sollte ich gleich ins Internet kommen wieder.
Nachdem er meine Proxy Settings detektiert hat.
Ha!
Es funzt!
Google.de
Massive, guckt mal, modernes Internet, Lukas Podolski Döner, Trendet zur Zeit, okay, gut zu wissen, herzhafte Spitzbubenrezept, vermisst es mich, Alter, das eskalatet aber quickly die Suchanfragen gerade, so, aber dass das funktioniert, YouTube, Massive, Qualität, PNG, ah ne, nur PNG,
kurz checken, ja, ich mein, Sound geht, aber Leute, es funzt, ich mein, das ist natürlich jetzt schon Trick 17, ne, das ist, äh, Browser, und wie hieß das, Browser Service, das ist nicht wirklich eine Windows 98, das braucht eine Kiste im Hintergrund, oh, vielleicht nicht so ganz in der Lage dafür, ähm, das läuft im Hintergrund, auf einer nicht Windows 95 Kiste,
mitten im Chromium Headless, rendert das und schickt es als Bild rüber in den alten Internet Explorer, ah, jetzt ist wieder hier, äh, Bot, Botgis am Start, Modcheck, aber witzig, dass das funktioniert, keck, wait, so, und jetzt kriegt es wieder Netzwerk, äh, Netzwerk entzogen, ich trau der Sache nicht, äh, aber ist cool, dass das funktioniert, bin ich extremely pog,
mal gucken, ob jetzt nach dem Neustart auch das auf einmal funktioniert, nein, das funktioniert immer nicht, und was mich auch, was mich auch sehr irritiert ist, dass nach jedem Reboot, Run DLL 32, Cost and Error hat, Moment, ich kann nicht mal mal rebooten, wait a minute, mein Reboot ist kaputt, darf ich mich jetzt ausloggen, ne, also, ich glaube, es ist ziemlich broken, ja, Shutdown, ah, das, das ist das fucking Windows XP,
ey, Shutdown-Ding, was ist denn das hier jetzt auf einmal, ne, das ist einfach das Shutdown-Programm, was mit dem neuesten Update da drauf gekommen ist, wait, ich kann immer mehr neu starten, Alter, ups, was haben wir jetzt gemacht, nein, nein, nein, ich, Moment, ich will nicht die Firewall-Tools reinstallen, nein, nein, ich hab mich verklickt, ich will, ich will restart, das war bei SP1 dabei, also, ich vermiss die Zeiten wirklich nicht, was das angeht, das ist so pepega kaputt, alles immer,
das macht, das macht auch einen super fragilen Eindruck, ich mein, starten geht, aber stoppen geht nicht, ja, nice, Max, übrigens, mal was anderes an der Stelle, habt ihr gesehen, dass es weitere vom Rackman, dass es weitere White-Pepo-Happy-Backgrounds gibt,
habe ich vor zwei Stunden geupdatet, es gibt zwei neue, es gibt,
zwei neue Backgrounds, nämlich, einmal den Solder-Champ und Recycle-Story, es wird langsam richtig, richtig viel hier, da ist ja wirklich jetzt für jeden was dabei, außerdem rotiert es, guck mal hier, Nudel mit Lachs, der weiß Bescheid, Recycle-Story, Alter, ja, find ich auch gut, ja, was ein bisschen komisch ist, kann ich denn, Moment, kann ich denn Shutdown,
Now, äh, wie, wie macht man, minus, R, Now, Alter, wie kann man Windows dazu überreden, ach, jetzt geht Neustart wieder, okay, Run-DLL 32 hat sich gefixt, man muss einfach nur oft genug neu starten, Problem hat sich gefixt, hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, wie ich dieses mega hässliche Background-Ding hier wegkrieg, es würfelt einfach, ja, vielleicht muss ich auch einfach die Netzwerk, das Netzwerk einschalten,
und dann hat es wieder den Fehler, Sperrbildschirm, äh, vielleicht, ja, aber wo stelle ich das ein mit dem Sperrbildschirm, und warum ist es jetzt auf einmal so super langsam beim Starten, am Anfang war es aber noch mega schnell,
Screensaver, Appearance, aber soll ich euch mal was zeigen, guck mal hier, seht ihr das, seht ihr das, man, ja, es buggt gerade ein bisschen, man konnte einfach, das, das buggt jetzt übelst,
rumkramt mal vor allem, äh, und wie ging das jetzt nochmal mit dem Exclusive-Mode, äh, kann das, kann man nicht irgendwo sagen, Exclusive-Mode, ah, hier, Exclusive-Mode, ähm, man konnte damals Ordner auf die Taskleiste ziehen, und hätte man jetzt hier was drinne gehabt, dann hätte es wahrscheinlich auch funktioniert, ne, ach, da ist er doch,
hier, guck mal, man konnte einfach,
Ordner auf die Taskleiste ziehen, und das ging dann, Sachen gibt's, oder, sogar, man konnte die Dinger sogar als, man konnte die Dinger sogar als Pop-Out irgendwie anzeigen lassen, da ist die Technologie heute auch einfach nicht mehr da, sollen wir uns das noch angucken, wir müssen uns eh noch zwei, drei Stellenanzeigen angucken, habe ich gerade gesehen, haben wir noch offen, so, darf ich jetzt neu starten, Shutdown, ne, okay, dann, keine Ahnung, was das für Schmerzen hat,
und was meint ihr, ist Windows ME jetzt so kacke wie gedacht, oder nicht, ich muss sagen, Windows ME war auch nicht schlechter, als die ganzen anderen DOS-basierten Windows-Systeme von davor, hatte durchaus ein paar ganz coole Neuerungen, warum das so super gehasst wurde, weiß ich bis heute nicht, es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlechter als Windows 98 gewesen, ich meine, es ist im Prinzip Windows 98, mit ein paar Kleinigkeiten,
wurden BMPs nicht unterschiedlich, weiß ich nicht,
können wir gerade mal ausprobieren, dann, dann setze ich, dann setze ich jetzt einfach mal wieder None, so, so wie es Default ist, und jetzt Restart ich, und guck mal, ob dann der Hintergrund wieder weg ist, ach ja, jetzt ist dieser komische Hintergrund wieder weg, ist der Pinball-Flipper, ich glaube schon, ich habe gesagt, das ist die OM-Version ohne Zusatzdinger, aber ich habe eben in die Settings reingeguckt, und mir war es so, als habe ich da was von Pinball gesehen, nach jedem Warcraft 3 Game formatieren, echt,
okay, und warum, hast du hier rausgekriegt, woran das liegt, benutzt mal ME zwei bis drei Wochen lang, ich kann es doch nicht mal einen halben Tag benutzen, für was soll ich das benutzen, es ist, Pinball ist dabei, ja,
äh, wie hat man nochmal die Dinger bedient, Leute, wie, äh, wie hat man nochmal die Dinger bedient, Options, Y und M, ne,
Moment, Z, Z und, okay, und jetzt das andere, alter, Z, ja gut, weil er hat deutsches, I, Moment, ich, ich drücke gerade alle Tasten durch, aber, ich finde die andere Taste nicht, Options,
Options, Space, ne,
Eier-Controls, Z, ach, Ride-Flipper ist nicht belegt, haha, geile Default-Settings, geile Default-Settings, machen wir U, wir machen einfach U, ey, es funktioniert, hey, jetzt geht es wieder nicht mehr, hallo, das geht nicht mehr, das Zeug war damals, weil Tilt soll bedeuten, was, Tilt,
was muss ich machen, wenn da Tilt steht, das hat meine Settings nicht benutzt, nicht übernommen, doch, hat es meine Settings übernommen, Tilt ist Game Over, ah, das ist, weil ich zu viel gewackelt habe, weil ich es dann kaputt gemacht habe, durchs Wackeln,
Alter, ist Pinball dabei, Alter, ich bin ja der beste Pinball-Dude überhaupt, äh, das spielt sich irgendwie ein bisschen von allein, oder, und jetzt, ey, warum drückt man nicht einfach immer,
Chatge,
warum drückt man nicht einfach immer beide auf einmal, dann kann man sich nicht vertun beim runterfallen, guck, einfach immer, einfach immer beide drücken, it's outplayed, hey, unfair, naja, gut, ich weiß auch nicht, wo der Sound hin ist, eben hatten wir noch Sound, und nochmal, aber wir haben, unser Sound ist kaputt, aber ich habe den Sound irgendwie ausgeschaltet, oder, ne, Sound ist,
ich bin begeistert, wie gut das funktioniert, eben hatten wir noch Sound, eben hatten wir noch Sound, jetzt ist der Sound aber irgendwie weg, und, und, wie, wie gehabt, sobald was nicht geht, einfach rebooten, und dann geht's wieder,
pass auf,
warum ist bei jedem Windows-Start irgendwas anders, jetzt muss ich mein Passwort zweimal eingeben, auf einmal, es ist wirklich immer irgendwas anderes, egal, was du machst, aber jetzt ist der Sound wenigstens wieder da,
okay, nochmal Restart, mal gucken, was jetzt passiert,
ich glaube, wenn ich neu starte, nur oft genug, und irgendwann haben wir alle Kombinationen durch, was passieren kann,
ah, das ist, wenn ich mich beim ersten Mal vertippe, dann kommt zum zweiten Mal Passwort eintippen, das alte, das alte, ähm, der alte Dialog wieder, obviously, logisch, ne, und das Beste ist, dass man Cancel drücken kann, und es lockt sich trotzdem ein,
das ist, das ist, das ist wirklich Monarch S, man,
also sollte sich, äh, einloggen, vielleicht macht's auch einfach gar nichts, kann auch sein, jetzt macht's einfach gar nichts mehr, okay, interessant,
ach, doch, ach, doch, okay, also, ein bisschen pepega war da schon alles im Kopf da, also, das ist, äh, die Microsoft-Leute, die das gebaut haben, Pictures, Cliff in Clouds,
guck mal, diesen Image-Viewer, den gab es mehr oder weniger auch noch unter Windows XP,
ein bisschen, nur ein bisschen verbessert, konnte man damals auch schon mehrere Bilder öffnen, da drinnen,
ne, das war nicht, nicht im Scope, mehrere Bilder zu öffnen, damals hat man halt Infra, Infra-View, oder wie das hieß, installiert, kennt ihr das noch, also, so ein Image-Viewer für, für Windows,
drucken, man kann drucken, need to install a printer, ja, ich glaube nicht, dass, ah, Windows hängt, logisch,
Druckerdialog wollte, wollte sich nicht öffnen, obviously, dass Windows jetzt hängt, oder, ach, jetzt hängt's nicht mehr,
Alter, das ist schon ein bisschen kaputt, das ist schon alles ein bisschen im Arsch, äh, was haben wir denn hier unten zu abwählen,
äh, Launch Web TV für Windows, ah, ja, hm, das funktioniert richtig gut, aber eine Sache muss man ihnen lassen, ich glaube, die Windows-Suche hat noch halbwegs funktioniert damals,
was war jetzt, Cannot Instantiate Ad-Rotator,
ja, ist ja schön, dass ihr mir keine Ads anzeigen könnt,
Winamp, ja, Winamp-Buy, ist essential,
so, jetzt habe ich irgendwas gestartet, was ich hier, Web, Web TV, kriege ich das wieder aus, irgendwie, vielleicht, so, zur Abwechslung,
ein Task-Manager, sah, sah, sah so damals der Task-Manager aus,
ja, anscheinend,
was Zeug, man, so, wer hat eben die Stellenanzeige gepostet, da gucken wir jetzt noch schnell rein,
DevOps-Engineer, 80 bis 100 Prozent, aha, auch Teilzeit möglich,
ups, bin ich, Stuhl übers Kabel gefahren,
ein DevOps-Engineer wird gesucht, bei, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man die aussprechen soll,
TerraActive, Active, könnte ich noch,
aber Teri, Teri, TeriActive,
okay, also, bleib mal da,
deine Hauptaufgaben, Mitarbeiter bei der Plattform automatisieren, das passt ganz gut zu DevOps-Leuten,
virtuelle Plattform auf VMware-Basis,
ist jetzt nichts, was ich da klassisch bei, bei irgendwelchen DevOps-Leuten sehen würde, aber okay,
Ausbau unseres GitOps-Workflows, das passt wiederum gut,
Betrieb der VxRail-Appliance,
ich weiß nicht, was VxRail ist,
Irgendwann freu ich mich noch, was VxRail,
HCI-Plattform für alle VMware-Workloads,
mit hoher Compute-Dichte,
okay, ich hab immer noch keine Ahnung, was das jetzt eigentlich sein soll,
Integration von VMware-Tanzu-Kubernetes-Clustern,
ja, das passt halbwegs in den Bereich,
Migration von Legacy-Applikationen auf die Container-Plattformen,
ja, passt auch noch irgendwie mit rein,
Solution-Design bei Interesse,
auch technische Verantwortung bei neuen Kunden,
Kontakt mit Endkunden, das ist immer so der Teufel, Alter,
Ist Storage, keine Ahnung,
Vielseit, interessiert, technisch versiert,
mit Berufserfahrung als System- oder Bereitschafts-System-Hauptzeit-Reliability-Ingenieur,
vertiefte Linien-Kenntnisse und Erfahrungen mit Docker und Kubernetes,
faul, aber clever,
ja, das finde ich gut, dass sie das,
reinschreiben,
da muss man nämlich nicht so tun, als wäre man supermotiviert, wenn man nicht supermotiviert ist,
um Prozent, ich meine, ich weiß, wie sie es schreiben,
eigentlich schreiben die das nur rein, weil sie denken, so nach dem Motto, ey,
ähm,
das, die wollen es, die wollen es auf jeden Fall nicht hören,
also, sie schreiben das rein, aber wenn sie dich fragen, ob du faul bist, dann wollen sie immer noch hören, dass du sagst nein,
ja, aber es ist tatsächlich so, also, ich würde das auch unterschreiben,
die besten Leute sind die, die ein bisschen faul sind und die Sachen so erledigen,
wie auch immer sie das dann machen, aber so erledigen, dass unterm Strich es bei ihnen danach nicht wieder aufläuft,
ne, nicht wieder auftaucht,
darauf kannst du dich freuen,
also, ja,
finde ich es sich jetzt gar nicht mal so übel, passt eigentlich alles mehr oder weniger dazu,
weil hier könnte man sich natürlich vielleicht ein bisschen darauf streiten, ob die,
ob der Betrieb,
der vor allem bei Plattformen so in den Bereich passt, aber
an sich, ich meine, es ist jetzt nichts, was mich in Verzückung versetzt, aber macht doch ganz guten Eindruck,
wenigstens nicht so viel Gelaber
und relativ on point, was Sache ist und auch keine 30.000 Listen,
was man haben will,
es ist in der Schweiz, in der Schweiz,
mehrjährige,
mehrere jährliche, so rum,
Firmen und Team-Events, ja, das ist halt für mich kein Benefit, ne,
das ist für mich das,
genau,
genauer Gegenteil, Alter, wenn ich das sehe,
Gehalt weiß man nicht,
ist es nicht so, dass, ne, in der Schweiz,
nicht in Österreich, gell,
in Österreich muss das, muss das
dran stehen,
Gehaltsrange,
ihr kennt, wobei, wie ist denn das
in Österreich, die schreiben doch dann bestimmt einfach
so Sachen drin, die komplett nichtssagend sind,
so, Gehaltsrange,
40 bis 150k, so nach dem Motto,
kannst dann auch nichts mit anfangen,
ne, das ist, ist das nicht
HCL, das Ding hieß ja
HCI, sagt nix
aus, ja, dachte ich mir,
und den hier hatten wir auch noch auf, vom
letzten, vom letzten Stellenanzeigen
anguck-Video,
den hab ich mir auch noch nicht, gar nicht angeguckt,
was haben wir hier, bei
eSolutions, ein IT-Administrator,
oder hatten wir das schon, ne,
hatten wir nicht, oder, hätte es noch
eine, ja, schick her, eine halbe Stunde hab ich noch Zeit,
diese Aufgaben
erwarten nicht, du bist für die Confluence-Überwachung
und Optimierung der Firewall-Umgebung verantwortlich,
was suche ich,
noch mal, ein IT-Administrator-Netzwerk,
ja gut, da passt das natürlich gut dazu,
ne, außerdem
benutze dir die Configuration-VPN-Lösung,
ermöglicht somit
äh, Windows-Nutzer im Windows-
und im Linux-Umfeld, ok, überwachst,
optimierte Web-Applications, Firewalls,
Waff,
Administration Switch, was,
du bist für die Administration der Switch-
Umgebung,
dieses Wort ist irgendwie pepega,
man, du bist zuständig für die
Administration der Switche, das würde ich mir noch
gefallen lassen, der Switch-Umgebung,
wisst ihr, es gibt drei Switche,
die stehen irgendwo rum, das ist die
Switch-Umgebung, die machen,
für alle switchen die dann,
also,
wir hängen einfach überall Umgebung dran,
dann hört sich's besser an, einschließlich
Configuration und Troubleshooting, so wie für die,
ja, ok, passt auch,
planst, implementierst und wartest die
Azure-Netzwerk-Umgebung,
ja gut, warum nicht, ich dachte,
ich dachte, da kommt irgendwas von Active Directory
oder sowas jetzt, wo zum Beispiel,
die Configuration von
Virtual Networks, ja gut, das passt
zu einem Netzwerk-Administrator schon dabei,
die Verwaltung, DNS,
DHCP gefunden, ja, also
die Aufgaben klingen sehr
passend für ein IT-Administrator-Netzwerk,
wenn es das 3er
Berufsverfahren in der
Switch-Administration, es wäre an der
Stelle sehr sinnvoll, eSolutions,
wenn ihr hinschreibt,
um was für Switche es sich handelt,
gibt ja schon so, sagen wir mal,
zwei,
drei vielleicht größere
Anbieter, die öfters mal
vorkommen, wenn man da Access-Points
und sowas dabei nimmt, dann noch ein bisschen mehr,
das wäre vielleicht nicht
verkehrt zu wissen, was es für Switche sind,
durch deine bisherige Erfahrung,
bla bla bla, ok,
Systemmonitor, ja,
ja, liest jetzt eigentlich,
liest sich jetzt
ganz, ganz passend,
wenn es mich auch jetzt nicht in super Verzückungen
versetzt, ist halt auch ein bisschen 0815, aber
immerhin nicht,
eines von diesen Anzeigen, die sagen, wir
suchen eine ganze IT-Abteilung in einer
Person und bezahlen den 40k im Jahr,
so,
so lasse ich das doch ganz ok,
Dugado,
Linux-Systemadministrator,
ok,
so habe ich mal angefangen,
auch dort, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe,
ok, erstmal jede Menge
bla bla bla über sich,
unser Erfolgstool,
verschiedenste Charaktere und ein gemeinsames Ziel
in einem tollen internationalen
Team, komm auch du als Linux-Systemadministrator,
männlich, weiß, deutsch, in die
Group One, deine Aufgaben,
also, zeig mal her,
du verantwortest zusammen mit deinem Team
alle virtualisierten Systeme, unser überwiegend
KVM, QEMU, ok,
KVM, QEMU,
KVM, verwaltest unsere
Managed Server mit oder ohne,
Plesk ist was für die Leute, denen das am Ende
vermietet, ist doch nichts für die eigentlichen Administratoren,
dann, oder? Du installierst,
wartest und überwachst, Hardwarekomponenten,
Gesamtsystem und Server,
Kleinsystem jeglicher Software, was?
Und, Kleinsystem jeglicher Software,
was? Der Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Wo schaust du die Angebote?
Das, was der Chat geschickt hat.
Du installierst und wartest
und überwachst
Hardwarekomponenten, Gesamtsysteme
und Server und Kleinsysteme
jeglicher Software, hä?
Den Satz verstehe ich echt nicht.
Ich überwache Kleinsysteme jeglicher
Software, soll jetzt was
genau heißen? Ich überwache,
ob einer den Windows-Kanal,
Kalkulator aufmacht, oder wie?
Oh, weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
So, was habe ich geschrieben?
Ich möchte eben vom Windows-Gedöns
zu Linux-Admin wechseln. Oh ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Da tritt man ja durch bei.
Okay, was wollen sie?
Du entwickelst eigene Skripts und Tools.
Ja, passt, das passt gut zu einem
Linux-Admin. Entwickelst
mit, ne, gemeinsam mit deinem Team
bist du für die Pflege der weiteren
Private-Cloud-Installation Proxmox
Open Nebul. Das habe ich noch nie
live gesehen.
Verantwortlich. Die konsolidierten Legacy-Systeme
gehören ebenfalls da. Du betreust den
Ticket-Support-Serbung des Bereichs Second-Level-Support.
Okay, zumindest kein direkter Kundenkontakt.
Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Nein, zumindest nicht so oft.
Kurze Entscheidungswege
aus
Zeichnerentwicklung. Okay, Perspektive, Oberfristen,
Festanstellung, Homeoffice,
Möglichkeiten. Finde ich immer gut, wenn es drinnen steht.
Nach Absprache mit denen,
das ist immer so eine
so eine Joker-Karte,
nach dem Motto, ja, wir haben es zwar
reingeschrieben, aber na, wenn das mit der Absprache
nicht geht, dann wird es nix.
Also wenn es ja nicht mindestens ein Betriebsrat mit
Betriebsvereinbarung und sonst was gibt zu Homeoffice,
würde ich immer das als nix nicht existent
ansehen, wenn da sowas drinnen steht.
Möglichkeit der Vereinbarkeit des
Berufs- und Privatlebens. Ha, da können sie
viel erzählen. Wir glauben es ihnen jetzt einfach mal.
Neue und hochmoderne Büros,
standardübergreifend, dein Wohl liegt
unserem Herzen. Unterstützt deiner betrieblichen
Altersvorsorge, vergünstigte
urbanen Sports-Clubs.
Job-Mitgliedschaft.
Jobrad, ja, das gibt es bei uns auch.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich mir das
Fahrrad nicht über Jobrad bestellen soll, das neue.
Postlose
Massagen während der Arbeitszeit.
Okay, das ist nice. Obst
und Getränke, der Obstkorb, der darf
natürlich einfach nicht fehlen.
Dein Profil, du hast ein abgeschlossenes,
vergleichbare Ausbildung, du kennst dich mit
Konfigurationsmanagement, Automatisierung aus.
Es wäre durchaus sinnig, hier die ein oder
anderen Sachen nochmal zu name-droppen.
Was ihr genau verwendet,
weil es gibt ja schon unterschiedliche
Schwerpunkte, unterschiedliche Tools.
Also geht es jetzt Richtung Infrastruktur,
Orchestrierung
und Aufbau, sowas wie Terraform
oder eher Richtung Ensemble, wahrscheinlich eher
in sowas wie Richtung Ensemble oder
vielleicht noch Puppet oder sowas.
Falls die oldschool sind.
Web-Server-Konfiguration
mit Apache
Nginx, joa.
Also Apache mache ich
in den letzten Jahren über schon einen großen Bogen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht,
aber seitdem ich
keine Ahnung,
seitdem ich entweder
Nginx verwende oder wenn es um
Reverse-Proxy-Sachen geht mit Let's Encrypt,
Cudi,
wenn es easy sein soll,
verwende ich keinerlei
Apache mehr.
Ich würde sagen, bei mir ist es,
HA-Proxy, HA-Proxy manchmal.
Also bei mir ist es, sagen wir mal, zum größten Teil Nginx,
gefolgt von, wenn es easy sein muss,
für irgendwelche Let's Encrypt-Sachen,
für Public-Sachen oder so, gibt es Cudi.
Oder ganz selten, wenn es irgendwas
Spezielles sein muss, mit ein bisschen
Loadbalancing und eigenen Health-Checks und sowas, dann
HA-Proxy. Aber Apache
ewig nicht mehr gemacht, ewig nicht mehr.
Und die Konfig ist auch so abartig,
ich habe da gar keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Was für ein Ding?
Was meinst du?
Nginx-Proxy-Manager,
das ist ja nur ein Web-Interface, was
unter der Haube Nginx-Konfig generiert.
Traffic mag ich auch nicht mehr so gern.
Traffic ist nice gewesen
in so...
containerisierten Umgebungen
vor Kubernetes.
So, wenn man irgendwelche Docker-Compose-Sachen
gemacht hat, mit Tags zum automatisch
Balancen drauf.
Aber die manuelle Konfig von Traffic finde ich
zu eklig und im Kubernetes-Umfeld, finde ich,
braucht man es eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Dann nimmt man den offiziellen Nginx-Increase-Controller,
wohlgemerkt den Nginx-Increase-Controller,
nicht den Nginx-Increase-EngineX.
Ne, ne, Moment. Man nimmt den
Nginx-Increase-EngineX, nicht den Nginx-Increase,
weil PP gab Benahmung.
Ne, ein Problem hast du mit Apache,
das Ding funktioniert.
Aber die Konfig ist für'n Arsch.
Software-Defined-Storage-Technologien
ZEV und ZFS?
Ich frag mich, wann der Unterschied
überschritten ist,
ab wann es als Software-Defined-Storage-Technologie
gilt.
Hochverfügbarkeitstechnologie...
DRBD! Alter!
Das gibt doch Leute!
Das ist richtig oldschool
DRBD!
DRBD ist quasi
Netzwerk-Rate 1.
Um's mal so zu sagen.
Was nimmst du sonst gerne?
Cuddy. Cuddy nehm ich gerne.
Aber nur wenn's ganz simpel sein muss.
Also Cuddy
nehm ich nur, wenn man Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate
braucht für irgendeine Public-Seite.
Ja? Wenn ich irgendeine Webseite hab,
oder irgendeine simple
Web-Anwendung, die
ein Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat braucht
und einfach alles sonst drauf gebalanced
werden muss. Für was komplizierteres taugt Cuddy
meiner Meinung nach nicht, aber dafür ist es gut.
Dann wollen wir noch...
Kenntnisse in MySQL,
MariaDB Postgres, Scripting-Kenntnisse,
Bash, Python...
Python...
Monitoring... Zabbix!
Eis.
Das ist... das... das die...
Das... das ich nochmal hier sehe mit
die Zabbix verwenden.
Ich mag Zabbix.
Ich mag Zabbix und ich mag Zabbix nicht.
Ich find Zabbix ist ne richtig
coole All-in-One-Lösung,
die leider ziemlich oldschool wirkt
in manchen Bereichen gegen
spezialisiertere Tools. Ich mein, guckt euch mal
die Zabbix Graphen vs. Grafana an.
Und das richtig eklige an Zabbix
ist einfach die Konfiguration in das Webinterface.
Das checkt keine Sau.
Dass man Python und Bash Scripting-
Kenntnisse braucht, finde ich auch sinnvoll.
Gerade für einen Admin macht das sehr viel Sinn.
Auch, dass das da
als Anforderung drinsteht.
Also Admins, die im Linux-Umfeld irgendwas
klicken wollen oder alles von Hand tippen,
kannst du eigentlich vergessen.
Und das ist das Problem,
dass man das nicht so gut versteht.
Ich mein,
man macht manchmal QEMU,
aber macht zu 99% QEMU-KVM.
Man macht beispielsweise manchmal
QEMU. Wir haben doch mal
in Raspberry Pi emuliert mit QEMU.
Das war dann ohne
Hardwarebeschleunigung, ohne KVM-Sachen
dabei.
OpenNebula hat nie was damit zu tun gehabt.
Du bist bereit...
Das haben sie ganz unten hingeschrieben!
Ganz unten! Erstmal alles andere
kommt der Deal-Breaker so quasi
so da.
Du bist bereit, in Schichten zu arbeiten.
Montag bis Freitag...
Nein, bin ich nicht.
Gegen Rufbereitschaft habe ich nicht,
aber gegen Schichtarbeit habe ich was.
QEMU war
auch dann mein...
QEMU-KVM-Lib wird
hauptsächlich. Also im Prinzip
ist es auch QEMU-KVM.
Das hängt ja alles sehr zusammen.
Ne, das würde ich nicht machen.
Da wäre ich raus an der Stelle.
Aber sagt mal Leute,
wenn man 6 bis 24 Uhr macht,
kann man
dann nicht auch einfach 24 bis 6 Uhr machen?
Dann brauchst du drei Schichten, hast du das ganze
Tag abgedeckt.
So brauchst du, so brauchst du,
so brauchst du ja im Prinzip auch drei Schichten.
Nein,
nicht ganz. Na doch.
Doch. Eigentlich schon.
Mit zwei kommst du nicht wirklich
aus, oder?
Na doch, mit zwei kommst du aus.
Du kommst mit zwei Schichten aus.
Die müssen dann
neun Stunden quasi.
Boah. Ist schon okay.
Also ich mein, es ist, es ist keine
Stellstichstellenanzeige.
Also bei mir ist ja immer die Grundvoraussetzung,
das was im Titel steht, was sie suchen,
deckt sich mit den Aufgaben.
Das scheint ja echt der Fall zu sein.
Auf Bereitschaft hätte ich definitiv, äh auf
Schichtarbeit hätte ich überhaupt
keinen Bock. Das würde ich nicht machen.
Gegen Rufbereitschaft habe ich nichts. Und der Rest, jo.
Ja.
Ziemlich, ziemlich Standard, würde ich sagen.
Ja, mit zu Geld steht da nichts.
Leider, leider auf der Fall,
dass gar nichts da steht, was an
Kohle, was angeht.
Was ich finde, ich auch so ein bisschen abturn
ist, weil ich glaube, viele
könnten die Leute richtig gut von sich
überzeugen, wenn sie halt hinschreiben würden.
Leute, bei uns 80k
plus, so nach dem Motto.
Aber das machen
sie nicht, weil es das bei ihnen
wahrscheinlich nicht gibt.
Oder, oder sie hoffen,
oder sie hoffen, dass sie irgendeinen
über den Tisch ziehen können,
so nach dem Motto, hey, vielleicht
macht das für 20k weniger, so nach dem Motto.
Ich habe euch ja die Story
letztens erzählt, von meinem
Kollege, der sich beworben hat.
Drei Runden im
Vorstellungs-, im
Bewerbungsverfahren durch hatte.
Und sie haben ihm die ganze Zeit erzählt,
90k plus, ja passt, ja passt,
ja passt. Und am Ende haben sie ihm gesagt,
ja das Budget ist leider nicht da, sie bekommen
bloß 70k. Und da hat er halt gesagt, jo nö,
tschüss, ich gehe jetzt wieder.
Macht's gut, gibt nix.
Direkt wieder weg.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was sie sich denken,
wenn das Unternehmen so machen.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung.
Denken die sich jetzt, wenn du die dritte
Bewerbungsrunde durch hast,
haben sie sich so von denen
überzeugt, dass du dann auch 20k
weniger nimmst? Ich sehe das komplett
andersrum. Ich sehe das so,
wenn ich schon quasi,
bevor ich überhaupt angefangen habe,
beschissen werde, fange ich erst recht
nicht an, oder?
Ich glaube die, ich glaube die haben da,
wie sagt man heutzutage so schön, ich glaube
die haben dort das falsche Mindset gehabt.
Eigentlich müsste man
dafür bezahlt werden teilweise, das stimmt
schon. Wie hast du nicht das
High Performer Grindset Mindset?
Das ist aber nix.
Das hier ist ein High IQ High Performer
Stream. Wir sind hier immer super
High Performant im Stream.
Gerade in den Streams, wo ich
3 Stunden nix mache.
Wir sind immer super High Performance.
Hyperscaler. Siehste?
Endlich einer,
der sich das gemerkt hat, was ich für ein Mist erzählt
habe. Immer Hyperscaler.
Wir sind
Blazingly Fast.
So Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich habe übrigens noch
einen Tipp für euch, wenn ihr ein Netflix Abo
habt.
Wenn ihr ein Netflix Abo habt, und selbst wenn ihr
kein Netflix Abo habt, ich finde es lohnt
sich dafür, mal
ein Netflix Abo abzuschließen und gleich wieder
zu kündigen. Ich habe was, was ihr euch unbedingt angucken müsst.
Was mir persönlich echt sehr gut gefallen hat.
Und zwar Blue Eye
Samurai.
Es ist kein Anime.
Auch wenn es auf den ersten Blick so aussieht.
Es ist eine
Netflix Serie.
Die nicht
aus Japan kommt.
Fand ich mega gut.
Ich könnte mir
vorstellen, manche
Ne, es ist kein Anime.
Es ist Computer Animiert,
würde ich sagen.
Es kommt nicht aus Japan, es ist kein Anime.
Aber man erkennt schon gewisse Parallelen.
Fand ich mega gut.
Der Stil ist
nice. Und
ich könnte mir vorstellen,
so manche ultra anti-vogue Leute
sind mega getriggert von manchen Sachen in der
Serie. Aber ihr wisst, ich sehe da
auch einiges kritisch. Und ich fand es in dem
Fall wirklich gut gemacht.
Genau so kann man eine Serie
heutzutage machen und moderne
Themen aufgreifen.
Auch in einem historischen Kontext.
Fand ich mega gut.
Der Stil ist geil.
Also der Grafik ist mega brutal.
By the way.
Also da fliegen die Köppe und
die Ärmel und alles.
Und ja.
Richtig nice. Also wer
Netflix Abo hat und was nicht ganz so
cutes sehen will.
Kannst dir sagen, ich fand es richtig gut gemacht.
Ich freu mich auch sehr auf Serie
Season 2.
Sollte es dazu kommen.
Es ist ja wohl verlängert.
Aber ja.
Wer weiß wann das dann da mal rauskommt.
Und manchmal sind ja die 2. Season
auch nach ner 1. guten Season halt kacke.
Mal gucken. Aber das kann ich euch echt empfehlen.
Fand ich mega gut. War ich sehr positiv von überrascht.
Die Vermutung hatte ich auch schon.
Wollte ich jetzt mal loswerden an der Stelle.
Also falls ihr nicht wisst, was ihr gucken sollt.
Es ist vielleicht
nicht die richtige Serie
für Familie
zu Weihnachten. Okay. Also das ist noch
nicht für Kinder geeignet.
Das ist etwas zu brutal.
Und man sieht auch nackige Leute und sowas.
Also das
eher nix wenn Kinder dabei sind.
Ich find's übrigens
witzig wie sich das gewandelt hat.
Früher wär sowas definitiv
ab 18 gewesen. So viel Blut und Zeug
was da unter abgeht. Mittlerweile
ist sowas einfach ab 16.
Was ich gut finde.
Okay. Ich geh jetzt was essen Leute.
Äh.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.